I'm very excited to introduce to you
today Dr Joel wallik because what you're
about to hear in the next 120 minutes or
so is nothing short of amazing our
health is one of the most valuable
things we have we all want to be healthy
and happy yet with so much information
out there how do you know who to listen
to How do you know who's telling the
truth when it comes to getting well Dr
wallik has degrees in agriculture and
veterinary science and has been a
physician for over 35 years he was in
charge of a Monumental study that did
26,000 autopsies on animals and humans
and 10 million blood chemistries he's
written 11 books he's been published 70
times all over the world he sold over
180 million copies of his book and CD
Dead Doctors Don't Lie and he's had to
sue the FDA eight times for the right to
make certain Health claims that are true
when he couldn't get doctors to take
note of the fact that the animal
industry because of his research had
aimit ated almost every birth defect in
over 900 diseases in animals with simple
nutritional formulas and that it should
work the same way in humans he became a
physician himself his work is now
changing the lives of millions of
individuals around the world if I told
you that almost all chronic diseases
such as type 2 diabetes high blood
pressure arthritis obesity fibromyalgia
migraines eczema psoriasis and almost
everything else you can think of was the
result of nutritional efficiencies and
that you could make them go away 100%
would that be of interest to you and
your loved ones if so the things you're
going to hear in the next two hours have
the power to change your life forever
without anything further let's turn
things over to Dr wallik appreciate the
introduction um all right I'm just going
to start out just a quick reminder the
thing that makes my view different is
that I have a degree in agriculture and
in agriculture we don't have health
insurance for animals like we do people
and so we just had to get rid of the
diseases in um agriculture we have
veterinarians who would take care of
animals and if he didn't fix it the
first time out to the farm the farmer
never called you back in human medicine
they treat you for 253 years because you
have insurance insurance has been the
worst possible thing for human health
because it allowed doctors to use you
for an ATM machine even though there
cures available they will treat you for
25 years even though there's cures
available there's no law requiring to
cure when there's a cure available okay
that's a huge problem as you're all
finding out now but you're going to
learn some things today that will help
you take care of yourself and the people
you love and uh of course I also have a
degree in veterinary medicine I'm a
veterinarian I also have a degree in
comparative pathologist I do autopsies
on animals and people I also have a
degree as a physician naturopathic
physician I'm a primary care physician
in Oregon licensed in Oregon and Cali
Foria for 35 years and what I do
differently from other doctors is I
treat people like dogs but they get
better because in the dogs we've learned
how to eliminate 900 different diseases
in dogs that still plague people we've
learned how to Triple the lifespan of
dogs we didn't do that with organ
transplants and stem cells and jankle
inur proteins and wonder drugs we did it
simply putting vitamins minerals in our
canned dog food their bags of dried dog
food and then we eliminate every birth
effect you can name and 10 times that
many you can't name
eliminate all those birth effects just
by putting vitamins minerals in your
food there's not a single birth effect
you can name this genetically
transmitted although doctors would tell
you they are but there's not a single
genetically transmitted birth effect
they're all nutritional deficiencies the
embryo okay let's get to work here we're
going to divide this into two pieces
number one I'm going to show you what
the problem is and then number two I'm
going to show you how to eliminate these
disease prevent them and how to cure
them okay well Americans spend more
money we've been doing this since the
second world war we spent more money for
healthcare than all the nations in the
world combined not more than any Nation
more than All Nations there's 204
nations in the United Nations and we
spend more money each year for
healthcare than all of them combin we
spent just short of3 trillion dollar for
health care what do we get for it we're
92nd in healthiness there's 91 other
nations whose peoples are healthier than
us according to our CDC the Center for
Disease Control of Atlanta Georgia we
ranked 60th in longevity there's 59
other nations whose peoples live longer
than us and God forgive us we ranked
41st and live birth and first month
survivability of our babies December
2008 Time Magazine cover article says
the annual checkup of American Health
oops the sorry state of American Health
remember we're spending more money for
healthc care than all the nations of the
world combined and the only thing they
can say on the cover of Time magazine in
December of 2008 about our healthc care
is the sorryi state of American Health
despite technological advances medicine
Americans are less healthy than we used
to be our our health is declining okay
it's getting
worse more doctors more Pharmaceuticals
more Insurance more of everything and
it's getting worse worse yet is the next
generation your kids are going to be
worse off uh experts in medical schools
tell us that our children are not going
to live as long as us if things continue
to go the way they're going they're not
saying that you're going to die at 75
and your kids are going to die at 72 15
years from now what they're saying is
you are going to be burying your
children you're going to be standing
your grave site bearing your children if
you don't change what's going on here
the doctors aren't going to change the
pharmaceutical IND is not going to
change we're going to have to do it now
the most important part of a human
being's life in the first 91 days of
pregnancy that's when the embryo after
fertilization the egg is fertilized by
the sperm the embryo goes down this
assembly line 91 days it's assembled
after that the rest of the six months of
pregnancy is just building size it's
like a car going down the assembly line
let's say the car is going down the
assembly let's say it's a Rolls-Royce I
mean we're talk about a quar of a
million dollar car or a half a million
dollar car when it gets to the point
where the fuel pump is supposed to be
installed there's no fuel pumps but the
car keeps going down the assembly line
and then there's a place where the
headlights is not supposed to be there
it keeps going down the assembly line
comes off the line the car will crank
but it won't start cuz there's no fuel
getting to it can't drive at night
because there's no lights that's what
happens call them birth effects there's
not a single birth effect that's genetic
all birth effects are in fact
preventable we've done in the animal
industry so let's look at some of this
stuff just don't think I was giving you
false figures when it comes to live
births and and first month survivability
of our babies we're number 41 the world
it says the USA shame that is not true
that is not true because you put up
money you you spend more money for
healthcare than all the other Nation
world combin so it's not America shame
it's the OBGYN shame if every OBGYN was
put in jail for 6 months every time they
had a baby born with a birth effect in a
pregnancy that they monitored after a
couple years it wouldn't be any more
babies born with birth effects because
they'd learn what I'm going to teach you
tonight so pay attention here okay now
what you agree with Sarah Palin's
politics or not she was a very powerful
woman she was a governor of Alaska she
was the vice presidential candidate for
this United States for a large party
political party and her OBGYN who
monitor her pregnancy allowed her
pregnancy to result in a very I'm sure
very nice child but with Down Syndrome
triom 21 Down syndrome is not a
genetically transmitted disease it's a
simple nutritional deficiency in the
first 10 minutes of pregnancy when a
woman misses two periods and then she
goes on prenatal vitamins it's 2 months
too late the first 10 minutes of
pregnancy if you don't have everything
that baby needs one out of 700 babies
out of the millions of babies that are
born every year in America one out of
700 babies in this country are born with
Down Syndrome somebody needs to go to
jail here folks totally
unnecessary how many you heard of
cerebral
paly there's a cerebellum little part of
the brain it controls your fine motor
movement so you can play the piano and
stand on one foot and balance yourself
and all this kind of stuff it's called
the cerebellum and when a baby's born
it's about the size of a tangerine if
it's normal but babies with caly their
cerebellums the size of a grape not
genetic it's just when there was babies
going down the assembly line the stuff
that was necessary to make that
cerebellum wasn't there and it could be
a size of a grape it could be half the
size of a cherine 3/4s of the size of a
cherine extremely minor copsy there are
somewhat modest some modestly severe and
some severe and then there's some
catastrophic like this young lady
totally preventable you see the embryo
starts out as a disc and then it folds
into a tube and all this stuff going on
if the things aren't there when it's
supposed to be you get these defects and
who should we blame should we blame
ourselves is America shame no no no no
it's the OBGYNs how much nutrition do
they get zero they in eight years of
medical school they get Zero nutrition
what is the most important thing in the
life of an embryo nutrition somebody
needs to go to
jail and then talk about all these cleff
lip cleff pallets these are all simple
nutritional deficiencies of the embryo
when the baby is a flat disc it folds up
it doesn't fold up all at once it's kind
of like a zipper as it's folding so
starts out at the top and goes on down
to the bottom and you get belly button
hernas you get things like um hidle
hernas in the diaphragm and you can find
a good Christian surgeon who will donate
his time to sew these little kids up
it'll cost you $250 that save the
children uh to for each kid to for the
anesthesia and the suture material to up
so they can suck on a straw and speak
intelligibly they're not going to look
beautiful like movie stars because
they're still going to have massive
scars and things but these things are
totally
preventable so now you're armed now
you're dangerous because you know
something and so when do you start a
child with all 90 essential nutrients
all 90 essential vitamins Minerals Well
before they're conceived before they're
conceived all through the pregnancy that
they're developed in from the moment
they're born and after one generation we
will never have a child with any birth
effect now how many of you heard of
genetics DNA you know that double helix
all that kind of stuff the double helix
and the DNA um was identified in 1953 by
James Watson an American and Francis
Crick a Englishman and they were running
up and down we found it we we we know
the secret of life now if you have a
genetic disease like diabetes we can
engineer in a test tube a normal Gene
from you we can take a stem cell for you
it will engineer a perfectly normal Gene
for diabetes and will replace your
diabetes genes with it and we'll get rid
of your disease I mean they were excited
nine years later they actually got the
Nobel Prize for it for mapping out this
double helix structure and I mean
science went to work they came up with
850 genetics tests 850 genetics tests
right this is December 2012 cover
article Time Magazine I just love it the
Time Magazine knows more than the
medical trade they don't know their
Anatomy though they say this Baby's
colon cancer Gene is in his right
shoulder
his glaucoma Gene for blindness in the
eye is due is in his right knee and his
prostate cancer Gene is in his left knee
well guess what to have all these tests
we spent $1
trillion that's ,000 billion dollar we
spent mapping out the human genome how
many you know in 2001 we' did it we've
mapped out the human genome we know all
the sequence of all the things now right
that was uh 12 years ago now to the date
when they got their Nobel when they
discovered it 19 53 Watson and Crick
Watson 60 years to the date March 22nd
2013 says he was speaking to the
University of California San Diego and
the um St Institute and he said Gene
sequency is not the solution to solving
diseases the solution is good chemistry
means vitamins minerals Gene sequencing
to cure cancer and um diabetes and
obesity and high BL pressure and all
this kind of stuff is irrelevant
everything they've done in the last 60
years with genetics the guy who got the
Nobel Prize card says it's irrelevant
now I said that in 1978 and they all
laughed at me of course most of them
laughed at me are all dead but but
Watson said you can sequence 150,000
people a day and you're not going to
cure cancer diabetes or any other
disease most of the experiments we've
done over the last 6 years have been
irrelevant because none of it's
genetic so I have a book coming out at
the end of this year it's my 14th book
this is the cover of it epigenetics the
death of the genetic theory of disease
transmission all the diseases that are
said to be genetic are in here and shows
you how to prevent them and how to
reverse them okay now here it comes now
be alert for this one this is it
now there's a very boring scientific
journal called food chemistry you pick
that thing up and you open up it's just
page after page of columns of numbers
and things just like carrot and numbers
and beets and numbers and corn and
numbers what they do they send teams of
of graduate students out to farms and
they personally Harvest some carrots and
beets and corn and wheat and Tom
potatoes and beans and peas and then
they run them to the lab and they find
out what nutrition's in them and they
find out what pollution is in them then
they follow that Farmer's um Harvest to
the stores and they rerun it again for
nutrition and pollution see what
pollution was added to it during the pro
processing and getting there and how
much nutrition was lost during the
packaging and shipping and re
unpackaging and and putting on the store
well in April 2012 April 16 this issue
said commercial available baby foods I
looked at eight of them we're talking
about Gerber Similac infil very trusted
names in America okay commercially
available baby foods may contain less
than 20% of the recommended levels of
many minerals and vitamins less than 20%
dog food has 100% laboratory rat food
has 100% laboratory rabbit food has 100%
chicken sheep Pig horse cow food has
100% And your babies and grandbabies
have less than 20% why is that because
the medical trade in 8 years in medical
school gets no nutrition they just train
them how to take your credit card and
how to prescribe
prescriptions that's it this is the
cause of most of our problems right here
and so now I'm going to tell you
remember I have a degree in agriculture
I'm a veterinarian I'm a comparative
pathologist in one project for National
Institutes of Health at Emer University
I did over 20,000 autopsies 20 million
chemistries is published in a 12200 page
book that's in the Smithsonian Institute
as a National Treasure I then went on
became a physician because I couldn't
get doctors to do what I was saying to
do so I went and did it
myself sometimes you just got to do it
and so that's where I come from while in
the veterinary industry we've eliminated
900 different diseases still plague
people not with Wonder drugs and stem
cells and organ transplants and Gally
inine proteins we did it simply by
putting vitamins and minerals in our dog
food we eliminate every birth effect you
can aim in 10 times that many you
can just simply by putting vitamins
minerals in dog food we've tripled the
lifespan six years ago an old dog was 8
years old today an old dog is 25 we did
that simply by putting vitamins and
minerals in their dog food and so I
decided to treat people like dogs and
you know what they got
better Newsweek magazine cover story and
that's that's most people's initial
reaction they get a little giggle out of
this kid he thinks he's won the lottery
he's clutching this nice warm envelope
full of super sized french fries he is
one happy kid right but he's doomed he
says when I grow up I'm going to weigh
300 lb help it's not genetic it's
actually a simple nutritional deficiency
disease I don't know if how many of you
know this but I actually wrote a book I
don't know n early 2004 something like
that called Hell's Kitchen it was
actually based on a sermon that I gave
my own church uh in San Diego and the
pastor gave me permission we have a CD
of it and I said pastor I want to call
it Hell's Kitchen he thought for me he
said well hell yeah so I thought he was
cool and so we sell millions of that
little CD in the book Hell's Kitchen
goes into all the proof that obesity is
a simple nutritional deficiency disease
now how many of you know that we're the
number one obese nation in the world
spend more money for healthcare than all
the nations of the world combined and
the only thing we can brag about being
number one in the area of health is
we're the most obese nation in the world
and so what does that tell you about
what the medical system knows about
obesity veterinarians know everything
about it I can make Prime Beef I can
make beef with no fat on it so I use the
same principles right 1978 I started
it's a simple nutritional deficiency we
do this thousands of times a day now we
get people lose 140 pounds in 100 days
we get people lose 90 lbs uh in 75 days
we get thousands of people every day to
lose 50 lbs in a couple of months very
simple stuff once you know what button
to push it's easy now here comes the
beauty of this whole thing June 20th
2013 the AMA declared obesity disease
well
Hallelujah see prior to that time they
said obesity is just people making bad
choices in food and lack of exercise and
too much screen time and all that kind
of stuff no it's a simple nutritional
deficiency I'm going to prove that to
you here in a minute say simple you take
the nutrients and it just goes away it's
real simple now I guarantee you they
didn't do this out of the goodness of
their heart that they declared a disease
and here's why I say this the medical
system because of this this new health
care thing coming on is hurting
particularly specialist Medicare when
the doctor bills Medicare for 100 bucks
they Medicare only pays them 20 so the
primary care physicians the family
doctors aren't referring patients out
anymore you know a primary care
physician can do a hip replacement
operation
there's no La that says he can't a
primary care physician can write
prescriptions for radiology to do heart
tests and he can then prescribe you the
same drugs that a specialist would and
so suddenly now the family doctors are
keeping the the complicated patients
because Medicare is not paying much
anymore so the Specialists are starving
they're looking around they're selling
their businesses to hospitals hospitals
are tripling the prices of test and
prosthesis and surgeries and and
procedures and drugs because they have
no competition on the field anymore more
so they just triple the price once they
bought up the last doctor practice in
town they just triple the price they
have no competitors anymore that lovely
now so why then did doctors declare
obesity disease because insurance pays
for
diseases they said well where where all
the fish at well the fish are in obesity
and so we'll declare disease now so
insurance will pay for it now we can
make our house payment that's why they
did it it's not because of the goodness
of their heart
how many you heard ADD ADHD and autism
it has nothing to do with vaccinations
none those things have anything to do
with vaccinations I'm a pathologist so I
do crazy things I I I looked at batch
numbers that nobody else did before I
look at batch numbers on vaccinations
there's only a you know less than a
dozen manufacturers of childhood
vaccinations and then they re they
private label them to all the
distribution companies and everything
use the same raw materials they have the
same batch numbers no matter what whose
labels on there they use the same batch
numbers and they use the same batch num
in Africa and Asia and Europe and North
America and Central America and South
America but 95% of all autism ADD and
ADHD 95% is in this country so it's not
the vaccinations let's see remember food
chemistry April 16th
2012 our babies are getting less than
20% of the nutrients they require your
brain requires nutrients you're getting
less I mean there's no nutrition in
Fruity Pebbles and apple juice there's
no nutrition in Sugar Frosted Flakes and
Welches grape juice there's no nutrition
in agos are an oatmeal and Sunny
Delight that's why we have all these
problems these kids because their brains
are dying of
malnutrition not
vaccinations how many you heard
Alzheimer disease raise your hand this
article came out obviously February of
this year said Alzheimer's patients
could triple by 2050 well I guarantee
you they are because there's 80 million
baby boomers coming along who are
reaching that age they over 65 now and
so there's 80 million of them that's
onethird of our population so they're
going to Triple I me this just simple
fourth grade math is not a big deal
right uh doctors say help us we we need
to find something to help us keep the
number of alzer's patients down to 13.8
million a year I'm going to show you how
to eliminate it because it's a physic
caused disease aler disease did not
exist in any way shape or form in
1942 today it's number four killer of
adults over the age of
65 look at who owns all the hospices
medical doctors now here comes the
medical doctors I thought politicians
were bad but medical doctors are the
only people who can say three lies in
the same sentence Alzheimer's is the
only disease amongst the top six killers
in the USA for which there's no
prevention cure or treatment that none
of those three are
true doctors are so terrible when it
comes to dementia if you reach the age
of 65 one and three of Americans who
reach age 65 will die from dementia they
suck when it comes to this my grandkids
would
say now why do our kids die before we do
right now there's more kids kids under
the age of 18 dying of stroke in America
than people over the age of 65 that's
because stroke is not genetic stroke is
not an accidental thing or just some
dumb thing happening I actually sued the
FDA over this and I prevailed but
doctors don't pay attention to those
sorts of things they keep doing what
they do right so what causes stroke it's
a deficiency of or a ratio problem
between Omega-3s sixes and nines I
actually sued the FDA over this to be
able to say you can supplement with
omega-3s and actually reduce and
eliminate thrombotic stroke blood clouds
in the brain coronary thrombosis
pulmonary embolism and deep Vin
thrombosis before I sued the FDA and
federal court and prevailed with my own
money no no we didn't have any
organization that was my money because
it couldn't stand it anymore you see
there's no Omega-3s and Cheerios or
oatmeal or Sunny
Delight you you only say before I sued
them you can only say eating foods rich
in Omega-3s could reduce the risk of
thrombotic stroke and Cario thrombosis I
had to sue them to be able to say like
I'm telling you tonight you can
supplement properly and guarantee you're
never going to have that problem okay
now I'm 74 years old I've never been to
a doctor in the last 65 years never been
on a prescription medication I don't
have any health problems nobody's going
to steal an airplane with me on it I
find it amusing that they'll take your
fingerna Clipper away from you and I can
kill three people in a minute with my
ballpoint pen government is typically
stupid
right a ARP American Association retired
people they're marketing to 55y olds now
I I love that okay March 2012 a little
over a year ago cover article the worst
place to be an American when you're sick
as an American Hospital I took two
pieces out of the article and says the
number of American patients who die each
year from American Hospital err is equal
to four jumbo jet crashing each week say
1,500 people 3,000 every two weeks 6,000
a month 72,000 a year if you knew that
commercial airlines killed 72,000
passengers a year how many of you would
fly nobody would fly
got to go see my doctor I got to go see
my doctor I got to go see my doctor okay
then it also said in that article each
US Surgeon operates on the wrong person
wrong body part as often as 40 times a
week even a three-year-old knows left
from right that was in March in December
of
2012 each surgeon in the United States
makes thousands of
Errors they get a walk now why is that
1914 almost exactly 100 years ago
medical doctors legislated themselves
into a protected Monopoly there's thing
called the flection report back in
1914 they legislated themselves into a
protected Monopoly they're the only
legal Monopoly in America they
legislated not only did they legislate
themselves into being Monopoly but they
legislated all their competition into
being quacks if you're not an MD or a
quack the federal government the state
government the county and City only
recognizes MDS the military only
recognized MDS yet they have failed as
terribly we ranked 92nd in the world in
healthfulness we ranked 60th longevity
and we rank 41st live birth and and
first one survivability were babies
there's no competition you see I can't
go to a public meeting and say you don't
have to take drugs for diabetes for 30
years and go blind get your legs cut off
and have 25 years of your life go away
and gain too much weight and all this
kind of stuff with a little simple
nutritional program which we call the
healthy blood sugar pack you know
there's over hundred billion do worth of
research into that healthy blood sugar
pack sounds pretty simple healthy blood
sugar pack but there's $100 billion
worth research in that we've known for
70 years it's a simple mineral
deficiency disease you take this within
4 to 6 weeks you'll be off your
medication and be an ex diabetic is that
simple Newsweek magazine cover article
August 2011 the one word that will save
your life in a hospital it's a
two-letter word that every two-year-old
knows no okay we've given you six rounds
of chemotherapy now you have three
minutes to live we want to try this new
experimental drug on you that's because
the FDA requires them to tell them how
many people out of every hundred they
give the drug to how many are killed by
the drug they're using you as a guinea
pig when they say you've only got weeks
to live and we want to try this new
experimental drug on you has to find out
if it kills you or not and so you should
say
no wouldn't you rather the last two
weeks of your life wouldn't you rather
be in your own bed with your dog on your
lap hugging your grandkids then instead
of when your grandkid comes to the
hospital because everybody knows you
only have days or weeks to live and the
nurse says I'm sorry honey you can't go
in to see your grandma now she's being
killed by the doctor that's what it
translates to you can't see your you
can't see your grandma now she's
intensive care what kind of nonsense is
that stop taking them to a hospice
hospice nurses will come to your home do
hospice at home don't give those doctors
every last penny the family has that's a
centerfold from that issue in Newsweek
magazine what is he afraid of this is a
universal fear posture right no matter
what language you speak no matter what
color you are this is a fear posture
whether it's Spacemen or Godzilla or
whatever right and so what is he afraid
of well I'll tell you there's seven
doctors on the opposing page coming to
him I want you to look at them and see
if they're coming to them him with a
good Christian heart they look like a
scene from The Night of the Walking Dead
TV
series that's because he's the only one
in the hospital with money they're all
after him everybody else in the hospital
is a Medicare patient and they don't
want them they'll kill each other trying
to get to
him Readers Digest very warm fuzzy
magazine you find it in all professional
waiting rooms whether an attorney or an
architect or a doctor a veterinarian a
dentist everybody has Readers Digest you
don't even need to read it you know
there's be warm fuzzy stories dog drags
a 2-year-old out of the house during a
fire four-year-old calls 911 saves
Grandma's life that's the kind of stuff
you find Readers Digest well in June of
2007 hosal mistakes you can avoid look
at the font size it's blood red is
screaming at you to read this thing do
you think every doctor made sure this
issue was in their waiting room I don't
think so um I spent 20 years in the air
force myself I love veterans and um this
study came out it was from the
Department of Veterans Affairs did this
study it was a self- study okay and it
came out in December of 1997 and they
published it to the public in 1999
hundreds of thousands of mistakes each
year in the VA system 3,000 of which are
serious where they take out the healthy
lung they leave the cancerous lung in uh
you go in for a hemorrhoid operation and
they take your cerebellum out of your
brain or something you know they really
dumb stuff and and 3,000 of those
mistakes are that serious the person
either dies in the hospital or they uh
are required to stay another year well
look at what the Department of Veterans
Affairs said about 700 of these 3,000
major mistakes they kill they kill 700
you know how many American servicemen
and women were killed last year in
Afghanistan 380 medical doctors in the
VA system kill more American servicemen
and women every year than the enemy when
do you get angry enough to do something
about it okay we have to do something
and what what it's going to take is for
us to stop going to them we have to take
care of our loved ones we have to take
care of
ourselves last year we set a record and
more servicemen returning kill
themselves than the last 10 years
combined that's because they live on
MREs which is nothing more than a meal
bar and distilled water no vitamins and
minerals so if you have anybody in the
service in your family or in your church
you need to be sending them the 90
essential nutrients they'll come home
they'll be okay they're out there
carrying those 80 PB packs they sweat
they don't get any nutrition they sweat
out all that nutrition this is one of my
favorite stories it came out February
2007 look at the title patient protect
the it's kind of vanilla uh the data
that I'm going share with you came from
the Journal of the American Medical
Association the most prestigious medical
journal America maybe the world in the
Center for Disease Control again that
Federal agency that tracks this kind of
stuff in Atlanta Georgia and they said
this article said using those two
agencies as their source of information
it said each year in America each year
each year in America medical doctors
killed K injured infect 15 mil of their
customers at workplace each and American
medical doctors kill injured infect 15
Mill of their customers at workplace 5.8
million in hospitals and 9.2 million in
the private office and Clinics now how
many of you would fly commercial
airlines if you knew that they killed
injured and infected 15 million
passengers every year nobody would fly
so we we went to war in
Afghanistan because the bad guys killed
3,000 New Yorkers here's one group of
Tradesmen here in this country yearly
kill injur in fact 15
million got a few more of these then I
think you'll have the picture and then
we'll get to the diseases but I think
you need to know what the problem is now
being a veterinarian and a physician
this is important to me this one
remember I said each year in America
according to the Center for Disease
Control which they also did this study
Cent for Disease Control out of Atlanta
and the Journal of the American Medical
Association medical doctors each year in
their workplace kill injured infect 15
million well in the hospitals remember
this is just the hospitals this does not
include clinics in the hospital there's
2 million in infections each year of
those 2 million infections each year
990,000 die okay now I'm going to show
you people say yeah he's exaggerated
what did I show you this you haven't
seen the next slide yet now how does
that happen how can that happen in a
hospital supposed to be a refuge a place
of safety and so any rate what happens
is they wear the same white coat the
same panty hose the same trousers the
same shoes room to room to room dragging
snot pee poop blood pus viruses bacteria
fungus and yeast by contrast in a barn
by federal law rent the spread of swine
flu if you're a visitor or a worker
every morning when you go into that Barn
if take a shower with disinfectant soap
for like 5 minutes you tear open a bag
with a clean pair of coveralls and boots
and before you go from one Pig Pen to
the next you're required to stand for 4
minutes in a 4in deep tub of
disinfectant and then brush your boots
off with a brush before you go to the
next Pig Pen we treat pigs in a barn
better we treat human beings in a
hospital in this
country okay this came out August of
2012 about 10 months ago now one
bacteria C claustrum defal which is a
human poop bacteria that's it's only
found in human poop of those 90,000
deaths each year from infections in
hospital 30,000 onethird of them occur
because doctors don't wash their
hands in 1993 there were 85,00 these C
diff infections reported in hospitals
30,000 which result in death 17 years
later 2010 it went up 400% to 300 oh
just shed 350,000 3 46,800 does this
chart give you some sense that they're
working hard to prevent the problem no
there's no consequences why should they
wash their hands if they were doing the
right thing that chart should look like
that this is what you're getting as your
hospitals
folks well let's look at Pharmaceuticals
well everybody loves Pharmaceuticals I
mean we have waren street drugs and of
course for the last 50 years the
pharmaceutical industry and the medical
doctors has been after the FDA to report
Adverse Events calls on herbs vitamins
and minerals so in 2007 they did it for
the first time reported in 2008 there
was 600 adverse event uh calls of course
the the pharmaceutical industry and the
medical doctors assured the FDA was
going to be in the thousands 400 Adverse
Events reports for herbs none of them
were fatality they were like fast heart
rate from too much green tea and you
know mixture or um they got a um maybe
itchy skin from something uh 200 of
these were Adverse Events from vitamins
mineral somebody takes too much vitamin
C they get diarrhea they take too much
niin vitamin B3 they get itchy rashy
skin no deaths well the same year in
2007 which they've been doing for 50
years they reported not to the public
but in the mortality and morbidity
reports which come out every week right
they reported it for the Pharmaceuticals
prescription drugs now it's in this
report here but but it's very difficult
to see it's down here in the corner so I
blew it up because most people by the
time they get to hear that they're not
going to read the whole thing so they
purposely put it down here very tiny
little thing I blew it up so you can
compare this 600 Adverse Events reports
non- fatalities with
482 154 Adverse Events reports for
prescription drugs that same year all of
these were
fatalities you tell me what's more
dangerous Pharmaceuticals or vitamins
and minerals but but but it's FDA
approved people always ask me are your
vitamins and FDA approved I say drop
your knees and give thanks to the Lord
they're not because everything the FDA
approves kills people every drug the FDA
approves every drug even baby aspirin
has a little warning on there one of the
side effects may be death this is a
yearly figure and this is another look
at the pharmaceutical thing Des by
medication error Rising now they're not
talking about the side effects of the
drugs here they're talking about decimal
point errors which I'm sure the
pharmacists thank God catch some of that
stuff when it comes in and then of
course doctors will prescribe three or
four different drugs of the same patient
particularly older people um because
insurance pays and they get a kickback
right and so they do that and of course
you get potentiation and that
combination will kill the patient these
types of medication errors each year are
tied to 1.5 million fatalities and
permanent
injuries okay you only you can stop this
when the do right prescription tear it
up in front say
sorry okay
this is the last one of this kind of
really bad series and we'll move on to
the next subject this came out in 2010
hospital care fatal for some patients
that's kind of vanilla uh results of
Medicare study alarming well that's
alarming the study was actually done by
the US Department of Health and Human
Services office of Inspector
General okay so this study was done by
the US Department of Health and Human
Services office of Inspector General
which is the auditor for Medicare okay
what they said was that each month not
each each month in America medical
doctors kill 15,000 Medicare patients
from simple tests and minor minor
procedures they kill 15,000 Medicare
patients each month that's 180,000 a
year if you're overage 65 and you knew
the commercial airlines killed 180,000
seniors over age 65 every year you'd say
honey cancel the airplane flight I
turned 65 yesterday we're going
Amtrak I'm going to show you three
people three people very famous people
who died as seniors at the hands of
doctors for minor procedures Andy Rooney
60 Minutes retired at 92 his wife is 87
they're going to go on a world cruise
for a year and she was a little nervous
she said look we can't speak half those
languages the place we're going we need
to take a disc of our healthc care stuff
in case we get sick or that agent know
he said okay so they go to the doctor
and while they're waiting for the disc
to be cut with all their medical records
in it the doctor rooting through Andy's
um medical record he says Andy you're 92
years old and I can't find you have ever
had a colonoscopic exam you could have
cancer lurking around in you I wasn't
there of course but I could I know Andy
Rooney because I used to watch him every
Sunday on 16 minutes I just loved his
sense of humor and um I I can see him
saying well I don't have blood in my
bowel movement I haven't had a change my
bowel habits in the last 10 years
haven't lost any weight I don't have any
pelvic pain I don't think I have any
colon cancer that's what he should have
said but I'm sure the doctor insisted
and he should have said and he should
have said no instead he said being a
compliant 90y old he said oh okay okay
comes in the next day the doctor sticks
a garden hoses up his rump punctures his
intestine 3 Days Later he's dead from
peritonitis belly infection wife's a
widow and he never went on his trip now
when you look at his um obituary you can
look it up online it says Mr Rooney died
from complications of a minor medical
procedure what minor for him it killed
him Dick Clark the guy who discovered
the The Jackson 5 and Michael Jackson
the world's oldest teenager kind of guy
8 years old goes in for his physical
complains to his doctor he gets up three
or four times a night to take a pee
because you know he's that age 18 years
old and the doctor well you probably
have a prostate problem and send you
down in the hall when I'm done with you
we got a urologist to take care of you
urologist exams yeah get En large
prostate here a few lumps and bumps on
it we can take it out I can put you ah
head a list I can do it tomorrow morning
11:00 and he says well I didn't reach my
age by going to surgery for everything I
said do you have a prescription he said
I doesn't work listen this is an
outpatient procedure no big deal you
come in at 11:00 11:30 we're done 1:00
in the golf course we do this all the
time no big deal and and Dick Clark
should have said no but instead he said
oh okay goes in 11:00 the next morning
11:30 is dead 30,000 men in America each
year 30,000 men in America each year die
within an hour after the procedure
because when you cut on the prostate
gland either with a knife or scissors or
stick it with a large biopsy needle
releases a hormone called prostate gland
which increases your risk of death from
coronary thrombosis coronary or a
thrombotic stroke and he won the lattery
and had both
my favorite though is Neil Armstrong our
top astronaut first man to walk in the
moon he personally saved two doomed NASA
Mission save the spacecraft save the
crews but because of his technical
knowledge on how to communicate with the
machinery and the equipment in a
spacecraft from a computer on Earth I
mean we have more information and more
technology in this little um smartphone
than they had on the spaceships right
but he had enough he could save those
two Crews he goes in for his physical 82
years the doctors come out and said
astronaut Armstrong that NASA program
must be wonderful you're 82 years old
you have perfect health you don't have
any symptoms any kind your laboratory
world's work is perfect the other thing
we fine one car Ary is 30% blocked not
going to cause angina no chest pain the
ODS if you getting a heart attack from
that are very low but if you wait five
or six or eight years it's a progressive
thing it'll get worse you could dive go
to the hospital with a heart attack blah
blah blah you're fit now you should let
us put a stint in there do a bypass
you'll never have a heart attack from
that artery he should have said no but
instead he said okay let's do it 3 days
later he was dead from complications
resulting from a elective cardiovas
procedure an unnecessary cardiovascular
procedure we could clean that artery out
in just a couple of weeks there was no
investigation by NASA there was no
investigation by the state New York
State Medical Society there was no
investigation by the hospital medical
board what if Al Qaeda would have
kidnapped him cut his head off on
YouTube we' have sent in drones we'd
have sent in Seal Team number six
somebody would have died if they killed
our top astronaut but if doctors do it
it's
okay okay
cholesterol there's not a single disease
is caused by elevated blood cholesterol
normal cholesterol for a human being is
220 to 270 where did I get that figure
it's from a study was done back in the
1950s at the University of California
San Francisco Steph B hully was the guy
who a cardiologist and he's also an
epidemiologist he looked at 300,000
people other 300,000 6% had blood
cholesterols below 200 and start of the
study for 20 years he thought they were
going to be the ones that have the
fewest cardiovascular events and and
live the longest well the ones who lived
the longest and didn't have any
cardiovas events were ones who had
cholesterol of 220 270 he reported that
the Journal of the American Medical
Association you know how many doctors
paid attention to it zero because they
have all these cute little gals coming
from the pharmaceutical companies and
their little minis skirts the doctors
taking them out to lunch and they all
write prescriptions for meore lipor
zokor and all those core things right
the L your cluster
well I actually did a study when you do
20,000 autopsies and 10 million
chemistries you have a lot of material I
wrote 75 scientific Papers Plus that
book out of the deal one of my papers
was I compared the coronary artery
plugging in vegetarians and vegans
versus mediators guess who had the worst
plugged arteries
vegans because cholesterol has nothing
to do with it
nothing what plugs your arteries in
inflammation how many you heard the
inflammation thing that's get getting to
be new around right I said that 1971 it
was in an international pathology
journal in eight languages it was
published in Denmark all went around the
world everybody I had thousands of calls
then nobody did anything he used to hang
around 25 Pathologists we'd all go to
the continue education together we're
kind of buddies you know we'd have
dinner together and party together and
uh they all laughed at me said W you
must be sniffing glue everybody knows
it's cholesterol I said no no I did all
these autopsies and the ones who are the
worst are the vegans and vegetarians
because they stir fry everything in
coconut oil and olive oil they use a lot
of salad things for calories because
they don't get enough calories they
don't have any dense food like meat and
like that so they're they're um using
all these oils as a source of
calories trans fatty acids heroy amines
acrylamides cause inflammation ar ar
respond by
plugging well that was in 1971 here we
are February 2012 year and a half
ago federal health officials are adding
new safety warnings about the risk of
statin drugs the wiely prescribed group
of cholesterol lowering medications if
you take a Statin drug to lower your
cholesterol every day for for 10 years
and you are on a cholesterol restricted
diet every day for 10 years increase
your risk of alcer disease by 100%
you're going to get it and here's why
what is alimer disease alamer disease is
a going away of the myin the white
matter of the brain makes up 75% of your
brain weight it's the insulation
material in the brain okay when it goes
away the naked nerve fibers tangle up
and they Shard circuit and you get aler
disas now I can take a brain at autopsy
and I can never read the clinical
records and I can tell you by looking at
that brain under the microscope if
there's nerve tangles in there I can
tell you that person had Alzheimer
disease just by looking at slides of the
brain I don't even need to hear the
clinical records I because it's what we
call a pathognomonic lesion it's a
lesion that's Dro dead predictable is
gravity that's it there's no other
option and then of course that same
scenario will increase your risk of of
type two deabes by 52% what disease is
costing us the most money in America
right now
diabetes our alz patients are going to
Triple because all the Baby Boomers come
along who lived on egg beers and egg
white omelets and boneless skin chicken
breast and oils and margarin instead of
butter cream and L and tofu and beans
instead of red meat third world
countries don't have Alzheimer's disease
because they're eating meat in June of
that same year 2012 science is very
respectable Journal good cholesterol not
so beneficial I want you to email your
doctor and say I just saw something in
science news that said good cholesterol
is not so beneficial he will scream you
know like they do on the on his emails
and go crazy what that can't be true
higher HDL high density lipo proteins
and good cholesterol levels don't reduce
heart attacks that's because cholesterol
has nothing to do with heart attacks
let's say your blood cholesterol is 200
and 100% of it's HDL the good
cholesterol it won't reduce your risk of
heart attacks because cholesterol has
nothing to do with heart attacks when
you lower your cholesterol you have
cholesterol above 300 remember 220 270
is normal you want it to be in between
220 27 300 just means you're sexier
because you ever hear steroid hormones
testosterone estrogen progesterone 95%
of Sero hormones is cholesterol you go
on the cholesterol restricted diet you
give up eggs there ain't nobody home
anymore women used to go through
menopause and they're 7 years old in 3
seconds now women go through menopause
in 30 years they accept prescription
drugs that cause breast cancer you know
the hormones and everything oh they're
bioidentical that's just like saying but
the bullet is lead you know it's copper
jacketed there's not a single medical
screening test that prevents the disease
there's not a single medical screening
test that prevents the disease the glob
and mail is the USA Today equivalent in
Canada I speak a lot up there probably
about a month and a half if you count
all the days out of each year uh
screening is not prevention okay
mammograms of course are one of the the
things that women uh submit to this was
a 30-year study a three decade study
Harvard Medical School published in the
Journal of the American medical associ
excuse me the New England Journal of
Medicine and uh it was published last
year November
2012 and here's the results said in
women over 40 1.3 million of them over
the past three years
actually had um false positives that
amounted to 31% of all women diagnosed
with breast cancer with a mamogram 31%
were false positives this is in the New
England Journal of Medicine November
2012 the worst year was 2008 where they
had 70,000 false positives they cut
these women's breast off they give them
chemotherapy and radiation they put them
in the Cure Cal they know they didn't
have it and these women run around like
Judas goats oh you have to go to doctor
so and so he's so good he caught my
cancer early with a mamogram and I want
you get mamogram they said well
mammograms are safe they have less
radiation than a AAA Battery well they
came out 3 months ago and said one
mammogram has the same amount of
radiation as 500 chest
x-rays you know you can do a better job
at self- press examination even if
you're 20 years into menopause you self-
press exam keep a log 15th of every
month at 10:00 in the morning you find
something new you find something that
tender that didn't used to be tender go
yourself without the doctor you go to a
radiology laboratory and you ask for a
highresolution ultrasound no radiation
and it's actually more accurate leave
the doctor out of the
loop here's where the insurance fraud
comes in a push to prevent colar rectal
cancer get your colonoscopic exam
doesn't prevent it oh you had pops well
pops just means you're eating too much
Deli slices and too much sandwich meats
and too many hot dogs too much pastrami
or pepperoni pizza okay has nothing to
do pops don't become cancer PSA test a
federal panel says now no PSA test
anymore guys do not do it why because
just like Dick Clark two things happen
you're going to be one of those 30,000
die within an hour after the surgery or
you're going to be one of the 200 to
300,000 that become permanently impotent
they get Ed permanently and they're
incontinent they just pee all over
themselves it gives new meaning to the
term dirty smelly old man June 4th 2012
Time Magazine Health Science section ski
the PSA screen expert say PSA blood test
for prostate cancer doesn't save lives
that's because it was never meant to be
a screen for prostate cancer
most important part of Warren Buffett's
announcement that he was diagnosed with
prostate cancer was this paragraph down
here Richard ablin the scientist who
discovered PSA calls it testings wi R
use a public health disaster the guy who
invented it calls it a public health
disaster that's because it doesn't
diagnose prostate cancer and you can
actually through an examination you can
actually make it go up that's why he
calls it Richard appan calls it the guy
who invented it calls it a public health
disaster
okay now we're going to switch to diet I
think you got an idea that doctors and
hospitals are dangerous Pharmaceuticals
are dangerous they are not your first
choice you have to take some
responsibility here okay this was a
Harvard study they did in 1990 for males
and females in America came out in 1997
to the public and what they looked at
was lifespans county by county what
they're going to do is find out which
county lived the longest in America I
thought it was kind of cever and then
they were going to find out what medical
care what medical services they had
there they're going to duplicate that in
all the other counties in America and
and upgrade our average lifespan now
from a superficial standpoint you say
well man that that's pretty cool they're
thinking about America but they knew
that they were going to have to increase
the amount of Medical Care in every
other County right what they didn't plan
on was they found out that every County
in America has the same medical care you
can live under the bridge and be
homeless and illiterate never worked a
day in your life didn't never have any
insurance you crawl into an emergency
room you will get the same care that a
billionaire gets not because doctors
love you and they're altruistic and
they're good Christians they give them
this this guy living under the bridge
the same medical care that a that a um
billionaire gets because insurance pays
what they found out was the longest live
people in America are in the purple in
the midwest the Upper Midwest and the
upper plain states the shortest of
people in America in the old Confederate
states plus Cook County Chicago and Lake
County and Gary Indiana everything west
of the Mississippi river is in an Indian
Reservation yellow orange and red these
are the shortest lived people the people
in the in the purple they live 25 years
longer than the purple it's not genetic
what they did find out was how they eat
these people in the purple counties are
all people from Scandinavia Norwegians
Swiss swedes Finnish Danish austrians
they cook everything by roasting stewing
grilling how do they cook in the Old
South and in Cook County and Lake County
if you never again eat fried foods if
you never again give your children your
grandchildren your nieces and nephews
your Fried Chicken you'll add 25 years
to the life if if you don't even give it
any vitamins and minerals if you just
don't ever eat fried foods again that's
what this say this is a Harvard study
well 23 years later 23 years later the
University of Wisconsin repeated it
dietary habits not hospitals affect how
C's healthc care rank they picked
Pennsylvania because it was the worst
and the best it was good Bad and the
Ugly Philadelphia County where the city
of Philadelphia's in obviously first in
healthc care we're talking about most
doctors per patient more hospit more cat
scan machines more pharmacist more
prosthesis I mean more of everything
more massage therapists right but it had
the worst overall health you see it's
not hospitals with the exception of
bleeding emergencies that's where they
shine is bleeding emergencies but when
it comes to diabetes and high blood
pressure and heart disease they know
nothing when it comes to obesity they
know
nothing they don't know anything there
all they're taught to do is prescribe
drugs they don't know I can't forgive
them for that because they' had hundred
years for somebody to stand back and say
you know we're killing more people than
the enemy we need to stop what we're
doing until we figure out a better way
why is a dumb Farm Boy from Missouri the
one that's doing
it this guy's been dead for 35 years
he's still killing people fried food
causes trans fatty acids and heterocyc
amines and acrom they cause cancer
there's no doubt about that the FDA
knows that they keep preaching it
everybody keeps going to Kentucky Fried
Chicken so here's what I urge you to do
I urge you to take your kids your
grandkids to Kentucky Fried Chicken and
show them how to eat there safely
because they're going to go with their
friends you can eat Kentucky roasted
chicken
KRC you can eat eat their salad bar
that's it nothing else there is safe
same way with McDonald's I'm on the road
a lot so I eat a lot of McDonald's but
I'll just have their quarter pounder
with some cheese on it l tomatoes and
onions because I get it in 8 minutes and
it only cost me three bucks if I go to
Fridays the same thing will cost me $18
right but I don't eat the bun I don't
eat the mayonnaise I don't eat the
salads I don't eat the dressing and all
that kind of stuff I just have my burger
which is 100% meat and then I put some
cheese on there and I put my lettuce
tomatoes and onions and pickles I use
mustard cuz all that is is mustard seeds
and vinegar and salt and water there's
nothing else in there okay and so you
can be very selective no fried foods I
do eat I do eat their little parfet
which is a um a yogurt with 2 ounces of
yogurt in it it has four blueberries and
a half a strawberry I know because they
do an autopsy on them every time I eat
them this came out October 2012 just a
multiple just one multiple a day can
reduce your risk of
cancer one one particular mineral we've
known this since 1957 one mineral
actually went go went back actually in
1912 one mineral called selenium can
reduce your risk of breast cancer Ladies
by 82% if you take 200 micrograms a day
any any woman who didn't have her OBGYN
tell you to take 200 micrograms of sleam
every day should be put in jail for mass
murder you also if you cook your meat
medium rare instead of well done you
reduce your risk of breast cancer ladies
it was University of South Carolina did
this study came out in 1998 reduce your
risk of breast cancer by 462 I don't
even know what that means I know what
100% means but what does 462 per mean
reduce your risk of 462 per of breast
cancer if you eat your meat cooked
medium rare rather than well done
because of the heterocyclic amines and
acry amides that occur when you burn
meat anybody own a dog anybody own a dog
I've already given you the statistics
we've tripled their lifespan we've
eliminated 900 diseases that we still
have and everybody knows you can't give
table scraps to a dog because it messes
up all the ratios in the food you buy
buy food that's you know I don't know
what it is now 50 60 cents can for a
perfect dot perfect nutrition
biochemical nutrition and triple the
lifespan you eliminate all these disease
the only time you take the dog the dog
if you give them dog food the only time
you take them to the vet is once a year
for a Raby shot because that's the law
you have a dog for 25 years unless
they're really clumsy and stupid and
Chase cars and get run over other than
stuff like that um you only have to take
your dog for 25 years once a year to the
vet to get a rabies shot why why do we
feed our kids our grandkids food that we
know will kill a
dog so and I told
earlier I started treating my patients
like
dogs we came up with a 90 for Life
program how long do you need to take it
for life how long you need oxygen for
Life how long you need water for Life
how long do you need God for Life how
long do you need the 90 cent of
nutrients for Life who came up with a 90
cent of nutrients God okay the Garden
Eden was perfect it had everything in it
now everybody can't go there are seven
billion people on Earth we can take the
information we already we actually
analyze this so that we know what's in
the Garden of Eden
it was the first map quest I don't know
if you realize that the first map quest
is in the Old Testament the Garden of
Eden was East of Eden there are four
rivers that dump into it right kishan
pichan uh the um tigers and Euphrates
those rivers are still dumping into the
same place that's still the Garden of
Eden so I'm going to show you what's in
there there's 90 essential nutrients
they're called essential nutrients
ladies and gentlemen for two reasons
number one we can't do without them you
have to eat them or supplement with them
every day because we can't make them we
can't make them also if you don't take
them in you get if any one of them is
missing you get horrible diseases all of
which are fatal some take longer to kill
and others but they'll all kill you
deficiency diseases we need 60 minerals
2/3 of 90 C nutrients are minerals so
you know that minerals are important
that's the dust the gr Lord made us out
of we need 16 vitamins 12 essential
amino acids three essential fatty acids
our food plants our grains vegetable
fruits and nuts can take carbon dioxide
out of the air use the sun's energy in a
process known as photosynthesis and the
chlorophyll and the green leaves to Lop
that O2 off Pump It the atmosphere so we
can breathe it do you think that
happened by chance I don't think so I
think there was a overall plan for this
okay so anyway then the the plant takes
the carbon atoms and makes long carbon
chains which become fatty acids amino
acids and vitamins okay now nutritional
minerals do not occur in a uniform blank
around the Coss of the earth nutritional
minerals occur in veins like chocolate
and chalk Ral ice cream because I used
to ask my grandma those people down the
road were Helens they all live to be
hundred they never ate anything Sol
everything they consumed was White
Lightning they smoked they stayed up all
night and party loud music you'd hear it
three miles away in a flat land in in
Missouri and they lived be hundred the
pastors would died 42 and 48 and 50 why
was that the pastor just happened to
live on a piece of property that only
had 12 minerals in it and the Helens
lived on a piece of property that had
100 minerals just by dumb luck the
pastor can supplement can he now how
many can remember going to your grandma
grandma's house and they had a Grandma
and Grandpa's house they had a wood
stove anybody remember the wood stove
day some of you may still have a wood
stove or a fireplace what did everybody
do with the wood ashes every morning did
they throw them in the recycling bed to
save the Earth where did the wood ashes
go in the garden they went in the garden
wood ashes are not ashes somebody gave
that name thousands of years ago and
they kind of stuck affectionately but
that powder that's left in the stove in
the fireplace in the fire pit is
actually the minerals that the trees
sucked up out of the ground when you
burn the carbon in the wood the the
minerals don't burn they just fall out
as dust well there's that word dust
again
okay into the fireplace or the wood
stove or the fire pit then you take them
up and you throw them you broadcast them
out in the garden plant minerals AKA
wood ashes and the ochre and the sweet
potatoes and the onions and the beans
and the peas and the Squash and tomatoes
and the pumpkins and the corn and
whatever else you're growing out there
suck all those minerals up and
granddaddy did supplement people say
well my granddaddy lived be 102 and he
didn't supplement well yes he did he put
those minerals into the garden the trees
or the the plants sucked him up and he
ate those plants and he got his minerals
in that fashion he didn't have any a
capsule but he took those
minerals okay that all ended at 3:00 in
the afternoon Monday September 4th 1882
we know the exact moment because of a
front page story in every newspaper in
the world at 3:00 in the afternoon
Monday September 4th 1882 it all ended
this man here on Pearl Street on the
bluff overlooking the construction of
book Brooklyn Bridge pulled the switch
and turned on the first commercial
electric generating plant within 10
years every town and every city in the
industrialized world the First World
countries the rich countries had
converted from wood is a universal fuel
to electricity propane and natural gas
now you tell me how many wood ashes how
many plant minerals are left over in
your home when you fuel it with
electricity propane natural gas zero and
what did you replace it with nothing and
here comes a doctor strutting around
their white coat and their stethoscope
around their neck you don't need to take
them vitamins minerals they'll just get
expensive you're and waste your money
you can get everything you need just by
eating well you don't need to take them
vitamins and minerals they'll kill you
they're very dangerous you can overdose
in them vitamins minerals everybody say
oh okay you're the one with the white
coat I believe
you now this is a corn field in central
Nebraska I want you to look at the
uniformity of those roads the uniformity
of the plants and I'm sure if you look
at the ears of car they're all uniform
too they're the same genetic variety but
I can guarantee you just by looking at
that picture I can tell you that there's
enough magnesium which makes the leaves
green to convert energy from the
sunlight there's enough phosphorus
potassium to drive growth in those
fields because if there wasn't you'd
have bald spots or thin spots so you
know there's optimal mountains of those
three fre minerals that's all plant
needs to make good seeds for the Next
Generation humans in all vertebrates
whether a hummingbird a human or an
elephant need 60 plants only need three
you think farmers put in 60 no it's too
expensive you wouldn't pay for it and so
they only put in three because that's
all it takes to get the maximum yields
this my favorite picture this a
satellite picture from 100 miles up this
is Southern California Agricultural and
this Pacific Ocean out here this is you
um Arizona over here Mexico's down here
200 miles south of this salt and sea
which is a small Salt Lake about 1/10th
the size of the Great Salt Lake and Salt
Lake City of Utah but why don't you to
see remember I told you that nutritional
minerals occur in veins like chocolate
and chocolate rle ice cream this is what
you're seeing here all these different
Swirls and whirls they're different
veins of minerals and mixtures of
minerals different amounts of each one
so if you were to grow tomatoes in every
square foot that's about 100 square
miles because this picture is taken from
100 miles up when you grow tomatoes and
every square foot of that 100 square
miles down there could you guarantee
without supplementation that each tomato
is going to give you the exact same
amount and variety of minerals no I mean
you don't have to know anything but you
just look at that picture you know it's
not the same well in the animal industry
we know that and so in the animal indry
we put everything we know that that dog
and the cat and the chicken and the
sheep and the Pig and the horse and
turkey and duck everything that we're
feeding with pellets and and mixtures of
grains we put everything we know they
need in it when you look at a a label on
the back of a can of dog food or a bag
of dog food or bag of chicken food or
pig feed guess what the only thing that
shows up on that label is what we put in
there because if they were to analyze
each batch guess what that can of dog
food cost you 500 bucks the only thing
that label represents is what we put in
there everything else is was naturally
in there we consider that value added
and see every morning when you wake up
it's the grace of God you woke up
because the night before when you ate
dinner if you didn't supplement within
90 cents of nutrients you don't know if
you're going to die that night by
missing one of those that's how critical
it is eating organic doesn't matter
organic say less plutons doesn't say
anything about the nutritional value of
of the food they looked at 240 separate
studies where they looked at the amount
of nutrition minerals and vitamins in
organically grown versus inorganically
grown grains and vegetables and fruit
and guess what it depends on what row in
the field they're growing in organic
doesn't mean good nutrition necessarily
you still have to supplement that's why
vegans and vegetarians die long before
meat eaters let me tell you the top 20
longevity cultures on Earth there's not
a single vegetarian in the group they're
all
mediators they don't fry anything it's
too expensive to buy the oils they're
poor now this is the core of everything
we do we have 100 cubic miles of this
stuff this is a compost that has 77
minerals in it and is totally
pollutant-free that's the only place in
America that's totally pollutant-free
now that's because the road that these
guys are standing on a 3,000 ft
elevation so if the water would rais
From The Underground alers the
underground Rivers bring pollutant into
this stuff it'd be the second flood okay
it'd be bad' be like two-thirds of a
mile deep also this cap up here is 25
feet of marine Limestone we know that
because the animal and plant fossils
that are in there are from the oceans so
we know this been under the oceans for
thousands and thousands of years was
this from the flood I don't know but
certainly has been protected has 77
minerals in it it looks like coffee
grounds when you take a handful of it
and this is where we get our
minerals this is the core of everything
we do nobody else has access to this we
have 25 different ways to get the 90
essential nutrients one of the more
convenient ones we call the Healthy
Start pack it has three products in it
has 245 nutrients in it including 115
fruits and and U vegetable um juices 115
this is not V8 this is
v115 has all 90 essential nutrients and
optimal amounts this is designed for
perfect nutrition for 100 pounds of
human flesh for a month so you give this
to a 50 PB kid or a 50 lb from
Spain it doesn't matter 50 PBS goes by
body weight um this this will be good
for two months if you give it to 100 PB
person give or take 10 lbs that's a
month you give it to a 200 lb person
give her to take 10 lb is for two weeks
if you give it to a 300 lb person give
her take 10 lb or 20 lb this is good for
10 days you have to do it by body weight
to get optimal results okay I've been
doing this twice a day since I was 9
years old there's a big story to that
you'll find it in the book Dead Doctors
Don't Lie or the CD Dead Doctors Don't
Lie okay my wife and I took 10
years and we read every one of the 720
issues of the National Geographic that
were published in over 60e period we
found the top 20 longevity cultures on
Earth they have 25 common threads we put
all this information this book and I
found it's very interesting invariably
the top 20 longevity cultures they were
all extremely religious country cultures
that went to church every Sunday there's
not a pagan bunch in the top 20 I
thought that was really good stuff
there's a whole chapter on that the
religious beliefs and how it helps you
reach a 100 anyway we put the top five
of these 2 five common threads these
people have first of all they have five
generations living in the same household
conservation of effort they only have
one mortgage for five generations
instead of five mortgages they have no
need for hospice they have no need for
daycare they have no need for Education
great great grandma teaches the girls
everything they need to know and great
great grandpa teaches the guys
everything they need to know so they
have no tax burden right they have no
doctors they have no hospitals or
clinics they have no pharmacies or
Pharmaceuticals they have no medicines
great great grandma is the medicine
woman the wise woman who treats
everybody with herbs and plasters and
soaks them in mud and mineral water and
whatever she does right in everyone in
every case there's not a single
doctorine in any of these places top 20
longevity culture there's not a single
first world culture there not a single
Rich nation in the top 20 longevity
cultures and you have to take note of
this this from the National Geographic
they don't have any utilities no roads
no electricity no propane no natural gas
they common fuel as wood uhoh and by
dumb luck by actual analysis of the soil
by the universities in the country
countries these cultures come from they
get the wood they burn for fuel take the
wood ashes from that wood and put in
their Gardens they have all 60 essential
minerals in it actual dumb luck see it's
not genetic it's just dumb luck they all
get the 90s cental nutrients even though
they're from different ecosystems they
show you how they do that they come from
islands and rainforest and deserts and
grassy Plains uh they come from Mountain
sides they come from all kinds of places
but yet they all get the 90th cental nut
including the 60 essental metals from
their wood ashes they have other sources
uh like glacial milk as to run off from
glaciers that grind up the rocks and
things but they also put their wood
ashes and the wood they burn for fuel
grows on land that has more than 60
minerals in them they all live on a
calorie restricted diet how many of you
know that Calor restriction will add
years to your life there is a science
that came out in the 1400s the first guy
that that wrote a book on it called The
Art of Living long was Luigi carero
there's a whole chapter devoted to him
in the caler restricted diet thing I'll
give you an example real quick this
works in every species of animal and
humans okay no doubt about it what let's
take a a three PB male laboratory rat
and let's say he eats 2 ounces a day of
ralon Pina laboratory rat pellets what
I'm going to do is I'm going to take
let's say he'll live six years on that
diet if you do nothing to him you just
feed him he'll live six years but if I
take the nutrition the vitamins minerals
that's in those two ounces of those
laboratory rat pallets put them in one
ounce I've cut the calories in half but
I've double nutrition per mouthful that
rat will live to be 12 years of age
monkeys do it sheep do it pigs do it
dogs do it humans do it he wrote his
first book called The Art of Living long
okay he lived to be 103 when the doctor
said he wouldn't see his 33rd birthday
it was 32 years old and um he did it
with a calories tricked diet and eating
more wood ashes now these people don't
get any bad stuff they don't eat fried
foods they don't get any processed Meats
with nitrates and nitrites they don't
drink any carbonated drinks not because
they wouldn't if that stuff was there
but who's going to build drive-throughs
to sell that kind of thing there's no
roads no cars I mean why would you build
drive-throughs there a bunch of guys on
Burrows ain't going to work okay so by
default by default they're getting their
wood ashes or minals and by default
they're they're poor they they they only
can afford 900 calories a day these
people on the average take in 900
calories a day Americans according to
the um New England centenarian study
which comes out every year by Harvard
Medical School they say Americans take
in 2800 to 3200 calories every day these
people take in an average of 900 it's
not because they know low calories good
for them it's because they're just poor
they can only afford that their Gardens
are as big as this table here they're
postage s Gardens now they do get 20
times and 50 times the antioxidants we
do as actually measured by orac points
orac is an acronym or abbreviation for
oxygen radical absorption capacity it
tells you how many free radicals are
neutralized by the antioxidants in a
food this is where the super juices came
from mangustin goji asai berry
pomegranate juice um Patagonian wild
blueberries New Zealand blank currants
and all these exotic juices they're very
very good they they have high
antioxidants but they're only 125th to
the recipe Americans take in 1,500 oric
points 1,500 according to Harvard
Medical School these people take in
20,000 to 50,000 personally I take in
100,000 every day I kind of hit it hard
now this was the last National
Geographic we read oh yeah it's May of
2013 look at that this baby will live be
120 and when you read it and you read my
book immortality you'll see that they
read immortality because every point
they make is taken chapter by chapter
and I love it it's great because in the
Western Hemisphere the longest liveed
people in the Western Hemisphere are the
nans from the NCO peninsula in Costa
Rica Central America they live out in
the forest they're uneducated their
average lifespan is 90 they have 40
times 100 old we do they have 100 old
per 250 their population we have 100 old
per 10,000 they have 40 times 100 they
don't have doctors they don't have
clinics they don't have hospital no
private government insurance they have
Grandma and great grandma and great
great grandma what they got and they
have by dumb luck minerals that they're
taking their wood ashes and putting in
their Gardens now this child from
Central America is not from black Africa
not from White Europe or not from yellow
Asia this baby is kind of a Indian from
Central America these people live to be
90 and when they wrote this article it's
very it's just beautiful because the
last couple of paragraphs they say well
is Drop Dead
predictable as gravity these kids will
live to be 120 they're just living
longer and longer and longer they're
already living now to be 100 105 they're
going to live to be 120 and we can't
tell if it's genetics or dumb luck it's
dumb luck because they chose to live
there thousands of years
ago so they couldn't find the gene
because there ain't none as they
say okay let's look at billionaires if
money meant something for Health and
Longevity billionaires should be as a
group they should percentage wise not
numbers obviously but percentage wise
they should have the highest average
lifespan compared to any other
demographic in America and they should
have more hundred olds of money and
power and you know knowing how to get
things would help you I had asked him
that for many many years I actually had
a CD that I came out with what kills
billionaires look what they called their
article because I kept telling them and
calling them and calling them and they
said um no no no no no in 2004 they did
their own survey they found that
billionaires are killed by the same
unglamorous things to kill everybody
else heart attack stroke
diabetes obesity cancer suicide
because they eat the same stupid things
we do in 2004 there had never been there
had never been a billionaire Liv be 100
the average lifespan is 78 the average
lifespan of a falling down red wine
drunk in Charlotte North Carolina living
under the bridge is 75 they dumpster
dive in the you know in the dumpsters
behind McDonald's and live under the
bridge and they live to be 75 many of
them live to be 100 that's because they
don't go to doctors and get
killed well the the billionaires didn't
like that report and so so they said
look we want you to redo that so Forbes
Magazine did it again s years later they
redid it and came out in March of 2011
remember the first one was 2004 they say
as in March of 2011 there's still not
been a billionaire lived to be 100 all
the statistics from all the things they
looked at in 2004 were exactly the same
statistically except one one of these
subjects was dramatically different that
was the average lifespan one did change
dramatically it was lifespan in 19 or
excuse me in 2004 it was 78 in
2011 6 6 6 it dropped 12 years that's
statistically impossible in 7 years to
Dro 12 years ain't happening that was
driven I mean I could see him losing a
week I could see them losing a month or
something like that but in seven years
time they're not going to lose 12 years
how did that happen so I treat a lot of
billionaires they come to me with
terminal diseases they told they're
inoperable have less than a year to live
less than six months to live and I cure
them and so I have this big entourage of
billionaires who who follow what we do
they they love the 90 for life they got
their whole families on and so on so I
call them up and they said look I need
10 of you to ask 10 or 15 or 20 of your
billionaire buddies in your country
clubs one question for me oh yeah any
wall anything so I want you to ask them
if they've done anything proactive if
they've done anything different since
that first report came out from Forbes
in 2004 that said none of them lived to
be 100 they only liveed to be an average
of 78 did they do anything special
called me back a week later said well
that was very perceptible I like yeah on
the average every billionaire spent a
half a million dollar
$500,000 building fitness centers in
their house and their and their
workplaces in their offices and they got
these computers that were voice
activated so they could be rowing for
three hours and given the instructions
for their businesses and listening to
reports and everything from this
computer exercise is the most dangerous
thing you can voluntarily get involved
with if you do it incorrectly it will
kill more people than anything
else I'm going to tell you more details
in a minute so bear with me I you got to
do a little bit more before I get to
that piece so just remember that
exercise is
dangerous Steve Jobs died uh 10 years
before the average billionaire smart no
doubt about that lots of money no doubt
about that but he was an unsupplemented
vegan he hired a festar vegan Chef to
cook everything from him they spent lots
of money flew in organic food from
everywhere they stir fried it in organic
extra extra extra virgin virgin virgin
olive oil and coconut
oil and then when he got his pancreatic
cancer which is predictable because of
all those heterocyclic amines and
acrylamides and trans fatty acids from
the heated oils he went to the most well
respected most highly regarded most
published and most funded cancer
research Doctor in America bam he was
dead he died as sure as that doctor shot
him in the head he should have gone to
Costa Rica and find the oldest person
there and say I want you to feed me like
you're eating here's some extra money
give me what you're eating and he still
be alive
today
exercise exercise is a a very very
dangerous Enterprise the average
lifespan when you take all professional
athletes together all sports you add
them together the average lifespan of
professional athlete is 62 you take the
average lifespan of professional
football player when you take out all
the suicides is 51 there has never been
with the exception of three black guys
from the old negro baseball league days
back in the 1920s or has never been a
professional athlete ever lived to be a
100 if exercise is so good how come they
don't live to be 100 they get paid their
only job is to stay healthy that's their
only job when they get paid three milon
dollar a game their whole responsibility
is Eat Right supplement right exercise
right sleep avoid all the bad stuff
that's all they're getting paid for as
to stay healthy and perform they have
whole Seasons off and they still get
paid every month it's wild when you
think about it and their average
lifespan is 62 and none of them live to
be 100 well why is that that's because
when you exercise you sweat don't you
and people love you and you're sweating
in your job you're working in a factory
it's 120° in the factory you throw them
bales of hay whatever your work is
you're Roofing in the summertime you
know that kind of stuff it take plenty
of what that's what kills you because
here's why that's the obvious question
why because sweat is not water sweat is
a soup that contains all the nutrients
in your blood let's say you're eating 65
72 nutrients you haven't quite gotten to
the 90 yet the same principle is true
for 90 but the average person isn't
taking the 90 yet so let's say they're
getting 65 to 72 nutrients in their food
and they're sweating out 65 to 7 two
nutrients so here you are let's say this
is your nutritional reserves in your
body and you're sweating and you're
drinking water what's happening to your
nutritional reserves that's kind of like
replacing a quar oil every time your
engine Burns a qu oil with a quar of
water how much you do that by the sixth
week your engine wouldn't be very happy
would it so now let's see here you start
getting breakdown your acl ligament you
start getting a break down your
cartilage you start getting muscle
cramps you start getting loose teeth
high blood pressure diabetes start
gaining some weight oh now you got
fibromyalgia now you got lupus now you
have a heart attack which you may or may
not survive from shame on all the
fitness guys actually I have to tell you
this quick story uh I was called to
Atlanta oh this got to be 12 years ago
and uh this was to an LA Fitness Center
the manager was one of our Associates
one of our Distributors and he said doc
I got this whole new crop of people here
they've never heard of it I want you to
give a half hour lecture just on the
just on the sports piece okay it doesn't
have to be the whole thing just on the
sports okay so I get there and there's a
group about this size a couple hundred
people in there
and um showing my slides on athletes and
this beautiful girl she had to be 32
years old I mean she's dropped dead
gorgeous and she's in a $1,000 silk tutu
you know and all this stuff and she goes
oh Dr wallik and she gets stands up and
she's facing the audience right in front
of me oh Dr Wall it's not vitamins
minerals it's aerobics and exercise she
goes it's aerobic and exercise it's
aerobics and exercise she goes and half
the people in there hundred of them were
her customers her clients so they all
get behind her all cona dancing out it's
all exercising aerobic it's all exercise
heroics and it was the most disastrous
meeting I've ever had in my life I was
mortified well 3 weeks later I get
started getting hundreds of calls from
La we need the stuff we need your 90
cent of nut we need your sports strink
which we call Rebound has 100 nutrients
and a Gatorade has too so your 88 chart
with Gatorade so anyway I said why am I
getting all these calls from Atlanta
Georgia wanting the stuff remember that
gal that disrup your meeting well how
could I forget it's the worst meeting I
ever had last week 32 years old she's on
the treadmill at lunchtime, people in
there all watching her she boy she's
doing her thing gorgeous she drops dead
of a heart attack right there bam and
everybody in that Center called me and
got on the stuff it was a very expensive
way but you know she advertised for me
so I love her now the German American
medal Association 1982 the Journal of
the American Medical Association 1982
while running a man's risk of heart
attack death increases by a factor of
700% because it's all honey be sure you
drink plenty of water out there sweating
out your 60 to 70 nutrients you're just
replacing with water you're going to die
you're going to break down you can't run
an engine on six quarts of water when it
should be six quarts of oil it's that
simple this fell here ran a 100
marathons Brian Maxwell is one of the
top athletes in Canada he considered a
fitness Guru heart attack claims another
Fitness Guru dies a 51 of a heart attack
from actually the heart attack he died
from was a simple deficiency of a single
mineral I've actually done 1,700
autopsies on people that died of that
one type of heart attack I'm an expert
at it not because I'm bragging it's just
nobody else has done 1,700 autopsies on
people that died of that thing and so he
actually ran 100 marathons never came in
less than fifth had 14 gold medals three
the Olympics 11 were in the the Iron Man
things World Games and the triathlons
this guy was as fit as a human being
could be he dies at 51 of a heart attack
because he sweat out all his minerals
just drank water in his book you read
his book Jim fix the first guy I showed
you that orange book you look in the
index under vitamins and minerals it
says go to page 165 you go to page 165
it says don't take vitamins and minerals
you get everything you need from food
just run you live longer and thousands
and thousands and thousands and millions
of people listen to them why would you
follow somebody's advice who died at 51
and 52 doing what they're telling you to
do if he lived be 150 I'd do it right
but died at 51 52 is not a very good
recommendation this guy here collapsed
her in a playoff game Reggie Lewis
collapsed her in a playoff game with the
Charlotte horness back in 1993 28 years
old captain of the Boston Celtics
good-looking young fell Great Captain he
never jumped in the stands and beat up
paying customers and stuff like that he
was a great field leader on the court
and he was a great uh man on the street
he's just a good man 28 years old and he
collapses with a cardiy heart attack a
simple deficiency of a single mineral
called selenium and he didn't die he was
taken to the hospital and they were able
to keep him alive so the Celtics got a
team of 12 of the top Cardiologist from
around the world and while they're
arguing amongst themselves who's going
to be the head cardiologist to determine
whether he got a heart transplant or
what they were going to do with him and
if they did a heart transpl he'd be the
first professional athlete to get back
in play with a heart transplant so
they're kind of excited about that he
dies of his second cardiy heart attack
two weeks later because nobody gave him
50 cents worth of
selenium well here comes the real story
this is the story that I want to get to
but I had to pred it with that story the
guy who was going to be the head of that
dream team of Cardiology who's going to
take care of Reggie Lewis was a guy by
name of Dr W Thomas Nessa who's the head
of the Cardiology Department of Harvard
Medical School he ran the Boston
Marathon 20 times himself he was the
cardiologist for the NBA he was a
cardiologist for the Celtics he taught
Cardiology in the medical school of
course but he also taught it at CME
continuing medical education stuff for
doctors and nurses and this guy was
considered the cardiologist of all
cardiologists well year and a half after
Reggie died of that selenium deficiency
cop the heart attack Dr Nessa dies of
the same thing at age 48 now if I was
his family I'd be embarrassed to tears
and what a wonderful cardiologist is he
dies of a heart attack at age 48 he was
Dumb and dead he was Dumb and dead this
guy may have been able to take your
heart out not lose a drop of blood and
put it into him he may have been a good
Seam for but he didn't know anything
about Hearts cuz he died of a heart
attack and I thought it was kind of
Justice he died in a town in
Massachusetts called Dam I mean that
should be on his Tombstone died in
deim now I don't have a doctor I told
you I haven't been to a doctor in 65
years the only piece of paper my truly
the only piece of paper in my health
record is one piece of paper is my birth
certificate there's nothing else in
there I'm 74 years old everybody in
America be the same way just think about
it just think how humble the medical
system would be if everybody in America
would like me medically only go to the
doctor once every 74 years they'd be
real humble wouldn't they please please
I'll I'll pay you to come visit me I
don't want be alone anymore so let's say
just for theory he was my cardiologist
he said okay wall you're 74 years old
now you got to watch your blood pressure
want you to give up salt well if he said
that to me and I knew what his future
was going to be I would go around and I
would get every salt shaker and
Charlotte I'd leave a buck so they
didn't think I'm stealing them I'd build
a twoot frame around my bed and I'd fill
that frame you know Celtic salt Celtic
salt Himalayan salt sea salt Morton salt
every kind of salt pink salt salt Brown
Salt everything you can think of and I
get naked every night I wiggle around
until I was I'm sleeping in a cocoon of
salt every night he said that eggs were
bad for you because of cholesterol I'd
eat 25 a day if he said that exercise
was good for you I'd lay on that bed of
salt eating my eggs and I wouldn't even
blink cuz I wouldn't want to be like him
at age 48 dead dead dead now following
his advice this is what happens this is
the G here rala Pierce 19 years old was
Ted by every professional woman's
basketball team in the world she was 6'5
could do the Air Jordan thing she's just
a lovely girl and she she chose to say
look I'm going to take two years of
academics first I'm going to go to
Florida State make a long story short
halfway through uh her freshman year she
drops dead during a game at age 19 from
a ruptured aneurysm which is caused by
deficiency of a single mineral copper
she's drinking Gatorade go look and try
and find any copper in Gatorade there's
no copper in Gatorade there's a slum in
Gatorade they killed that girl as soon
sure as they shot her and then they have
the goal to say that she died of a
genetic disease she died of a simple
copper deficiency she taken the ' 90s
she'd still be alive today West Leonard
there's a playoff a sudden death playoff
in western Michigan for a semifinal game
make a long story sh he catches the tip
off he runs across the court slam dunks
it his team wins sudden death 54 to 52
this is him just seconds after he makes
those points his teammates lift him up 3
seconds after this picture is taken he
drops dead of a card heart attack age 16
now the medical examiner had a moment
here this is a this is a national Story
the medical examiner had a moment he sh
they got his name spelled right medical
examiner David star said the stress
Leonard placed on his heart through
Athletics could have played Noti these
wiggle words could have played a role
but his death could not be easily
explained it is explained it's a
deficiency of selenium caused by
sweating and drinking water or Gatorade
now he had a chance to save every kid in
America there because everybody read
that story that man should go to jail
forever when he dies a natural causes
his body should be fed to a rabid dog
that's the meanest thing I can think of
what doctors want to do as a result of w
Leonard dying let's do more EKGs that's
not going to do anything for nutritional
deficiency it doesn't show up on an EKG
this girl La dropped dead of cardiopathy
heart attack she's she was a um
cheerleader girl sweat they need the 90
cent of nutrients too especially if you
know they're going to grow up and have
babies if she died 16 years old somebody
needs to go to jail make a long story
short we'll get on with the next couple
of subjects we'll move on to the
diseases Theo Ratliff just retired from
the NBA 14 years his career was over 14
years ago he had bone to- bone arthritis
in both knees had cartilage pop off his
hip he caught a pass during the game
fractured his wrist the arthop surgeons
at the um Atlanta Hawks wouldn't sign
off on him so his career was over and uh
we rebuilt him using our healthy Bone
and Joint pack and we actually made the
rebound sport string for him has 100
nutrients in it including selenium and
copper and everything else you need has
nutrients in it and he played for 14
more years after the arthop surgeon said
that he wouldn't play he made $140
million after they said his career was
over now do you think his wife Christina
doesn't love me now next to Theo now
she's 6'5 herself so every time I go
over there she kind of hugs me around
the head and pants on my head she's so
sweet rebound you have somebody you love
who's sweating whether it's work or play
or Sports of any age you give them
rebound don't give them Gatorade you'll
add 25 years to their life and they
won't drop dead who needs doctor
this came out February 2005 special
health issue and US news report your
future physician might not be a medical
doctor you may be better off in 1993 I
said the average medical doctor which is
done by looking at 200 obituaries of
primary care physicians adding up their
age death dividing by 200 got 58 why
would you go to a group of people whose
average lifespan is 58 to learn how to
live to be 120 as God commanded they
didn't like that so they did their own
study said well wck lied the average
primary care physician family doctor
doesn't live to be 58 like he says we
live to be 56 six why were they so eager
to publish that well that's because they
were more interested in showing my
statistics were incorrect than they did
show that they were showing that they
died two years earlier so I will
apologize for giving them two too many
years okay now the last one in this
section is my favorite obituary and then
I'll get to these diseases real quick
I'm going to make a prediction remember
that Babe Ruth pointing out to the
center field Grand Slam home run Yankees
win I want to make a prediction here
copper deficiency causes white hair and
dry yucky looking skin he's a classic
example of a copper deficiency aneurisms
here aarta aneurysms so if anybody has
connection with him you need to let him
know he's in trouble it may make you
look Professor but remember Albert
Einstein died at 64 from ruptured
aneurism he had white hair just like
that okay last one this is my favorite
obituary George Francis oldest man in
America when he died at 112 in December
of 2008 this is his daughter reading the
newspaper to him because he was
illiterate lived out in the swamps
Louisiana didn't have any electricity
coming out there propane or natural
gas um he used wood for fuel and he
lived through 19 US presidents all of
whom the average lifespan is 75 they
only they had one at least one
University degree un less ear L than
they had two and presidents are cared
for not by dumb country doctors but by
very very well-respected medical guys
right but their average lifespan is 56
exactly half of georg's age and when he
died he's a black man and when he died
um at age 112 the reporters asked his
daughter what did your daddy do to live
to be 112 and she said he broke all the
rules of healthy eating who came up with
the rules of Health EA medical doctors
who live to be 56 according to their own
study she went on and she said he broke
all the rules of Health eating with a
died heavy on Dairy eggs and large
sandwiches pig fat cholesterol and
saturated fat I'm going with George cuz
he eats exactly like all those long live
top 20 longevity cultures once you
appreciate that the game changes
now you can't eat fried foods he didn't
eat fried foods everything was steamed
and boiled he ate like a
Cajun okay now we got six diseases to
cover real quick and then I'm done so
we're to look at six diseases obviously
we're number one obesities we got to
talk about obesity I promise you I would
teach you and prove to you it's a a
simple mineral deficiency disease okay
this is what's predicted following their
directions they can't be right so why
keep listening to if you just do nothing
you'll be better off than you do
listening to them just a reminder that's
what you're going to get if you don't
change what you're doing don't wait for
doctors don't wait for the government
because they ain't changing according to
experts 70% of our kids under the age of
12 are overweights 40% of our kids under
the age of 12 are obese meaning 30
pounds or more of their ideal weight has
nothing to do with too much screen time
has nothing to do with a lack of
exercise or eating too much has nothing
to do with any of those it's a simple
nutritional deficiency disease now this
is my favorite charts for adult people
who are
obese up until 1980 we were never above
12% obese it was like 10 12 11 8 9 12 8
9 12 kind of thing kind of like a stock
market but in 80 it jumped up to 15 20
years later doubled 12 years later 2012
it went up to 42% this came out in 2006
I got to move all this over and put a
red bar in here show that I put the bar
in there it's 42% now so what happened
here this one everything went wrong
doctors said eat more whole grains give
up fat because carbohydrates and Grains
only have 4.5 calories per gram and s
have nine calories double the calories
but here's the problem you
eat a quarter of a a stick of butter you
won't be hungry all day you eat a bowl
of syrup for breakfast a half hour later
you're hungry and you eat again and then
you get hungry again you eat again so
you're eating 24 times a day when you're
eating carbohydrates do we fatten cattle
on cream and butter and eggs no we
fatten them on whole grains uhoh what
what we fatten cattle on whole grains
you're told to eat whole grains your fat
oh well there you go this is not
difficult if they were correct for the
past 50 years the heart should look like
that shouldn't it but instead this is
what you got just like those CI bacteria
in hospitals following the doctor's
directions this is what you get this is
what you
get this is my favorite now I I deal a
lot with people who weigh 400 600 800 lb
in that range is what I deal with this
woman was not my patient but she could
have been my patient because I dealed a
lot with people like her but she had two
Guinness World Booker records when it
came to weight she's the heaviest woman
ever weighed uh they the GU Booker
records wouldn't not believe her weight
so they sent their own technicians and
they had a big um flat bed truck come
out with their own scales that they had
calibrated and she weighed 1,242 lb in a
7-year period between 1987 and 1994 she
lost 736 lb after a gastric bypass and
restricting her her calories down to a
th000 calories a day and then she died
because fat is not the disease fat fat
is the symptom of the disease just like
high blood sugar is not the disease when
you have diabetes it's a symptom of the
disease you can control your blood sugar
you're still going to die from diabetes
you're going to control your fat you're
still going to die from obesity even
though you've lost some weight because
it's not the fat it's just a symptom
stop doing what they tell you stop and
save yourselves okay here's the first
real clue this is not a rare condition
this happens a million times a day how
many of you ladies when you pregnant had
cravings that's because the embryo is
stealing nutrients from her faster than
she's taking them in it's the nutrition
deficiencies that make her eat and eat
and eat and eat okay it's choice
what she eats I mean grandma didn't have
Ruffles with ridges and Lays potato
chips you just can't eat one Grandma
only had wood ashes and clay out in the
backyard and so what would she eat she
ate clay out in the backyard and wood
ashes when she had those Cravings
there's no calories in Wood ashes and
Clay this guy loved light bulb she was a
big story in Good Morning America in
March of
2011 she loves wood paper products
cardboard stick she eats Rock dirt she
loves Diet Coke can not classic Coke can
Diet Coke can she eat the magnet out of
sh and she loves plastic bottles and
toys maybe that's why they took the toys
out of the Happy Meal I don't know so my
wife and I came up with another book
that I told you about this one Hell's
Kitchen and the subtitle is the cause
prevention and cure of obesity it also
talks about type diabetes and the
metabolic syndrome which are really all
the same disease these are all the same
disease just different sort of stages of
it um as caus this is not me that's
Alfred Hitchcock by the way okay this
book gives you all the
facts now here it comes loyal University
Chicago Medical
School exercise won't cure obesity I
mean they were assaulted by everybody
even Chuck naris who sells all those
exercise ma she TV I mean everybody went
after them but when they reviewed their
data they said by Godly they're right
exercise will actually make you heavier
if you're not supplementing properly so
eight months later when it was proved to
the satisfaction of Time Magazine was a
cover article August
2009 myth about exercise won't make you
lose weight cuz you're sweating you're
thinking about
that I I burned 150 calories in the gym
today so I'm going to Starbucks and I'm
going to have an 800 calorie espresso
latte Moka POA DOA Loca shoka now here
is another clue anybody ever work with
horses okay what do you call when a
horse choose on the fence cribbing very
good how do you get rid of cribbing
other than shooting a horse in a head
you give them minerals you give them
bone meal give them traal salt block
within 3 to 5 days they stop cribbing so
1978 the first Clinic I bought was a
weight loss clinic and make a long story
short people would come in every month
they'd renew their prescriptions for
thyroid they renew their prescription
for drug suppressor appetite but they
never gained any weight never lost any
weight they just stay the same they're
still 50 100 lb 200 lb overweight so I
said you know they're reminding me of a
horse that's cribbing so I began to give
them minerals I started losing two
pounds a day this is what a horse looks
like when they're cribbing the horse
isn't even there this is in a horse and
buggy Amish farm Barn uh south of Fort
Wayne Indiana I was there uh to see some
musard distopy kids but they were late
the buggies were late so I went into the
barn being my Veterinary self and I saw
this very typical of um you see where
the hor is cribbing along that thing too
cribbing on the corners there reaching
over cribbing over there okay they're
reaching up and cribbing along that beam
so cribbing is munchies munchies is
cribbing cribbing munchies munchies
cribbing so if you have cravings and and
you take our 90 for Life program
according to body weight one unit per
100 pounds of body weight per month you
to use the rebound instead of 2 liters
of Pepsi a day our monster our Gatorade
guess what you'll lose the weight you
start losing a half a pound a pound a
day you want to go faster we do have a
meal replacer called Slender effects
weight management system only has 110
calories per meal I make it with water I
like to throw in a couple of eggs it
gets up to about uh 250 calories with
the eggs and um that helps you cuz then
you're only going to have three of or
two of those a day plus a salad you're
cool but well I like to throw in what we
call ASAP as Slim as possible as soon as
possible as drops you put on your tongue
leave it absorb on your tongue it's so
you do one of those bottles per month if
you need to lose 50 lbs or less if you
need to lose 51 PBS or more you take two
bottles a month put two droppers full on
your tongue I'll give you a couple of
examples this is Jerry uh he had a bread
belly he wasn't a drinker wasn't a beer
belly he had a bread belly because his
wife Judy loved to make bread he was on
our our 90 essential nutrients and uh
but he didn't gain any weight other than
his belly just he had a bread belly and
you have to appreciate bread bellies and
beer bellies are the same thing cuz
bread and beer is made from the same
stuff they're both made from yeast and
wheat and barley R oats only different
is one is fermented and the other one is
baked it's the same ingredients so you
can understand you get a bread belly and
a beer belly any all he added to his
system for 45 days was the um ASAP he
lost his bread belly in in 45 days okay
lost 52 lbs Now ladies just to show you
that women can lose weight too this
little Brandy and she's 5'2 in this
picture she weighed 158 lbs and her she
had had three kids and she started
drinking two these 2 lit bottles of
Pepsi during her first pregnant she
gained 58 lb cuz she weighed 100 lb when
she first got pregnant and she gained 58
lb she got 58 lb of fat okay one3 of her
body weight her husband affectionately
called her his chunky monkey that's
where I got the term and she hated that
so when when rebound came up she started
drinking rebound and she lost 20 PBS
just drinking rebound instead of the
Pepsi I mean within a month she lost was
21 days was even a month she lost 20 lb
then we put her on the the ASAP and she
lost another 38 lb now she's back to
down to 100 lb now I suspect there's be
more kids in that family okay let's talk
about Alzheimer disease there's actually
four different dementias that Americans
commonly get number one the most common
one actually is vast your dementia the
same thing that causes a blocking of the
arteries in your heart block the
arteries in your brain it's called
vastor dementia and you don't get enough
oxygen and food to your brain there's
nothing wrong with your brain there's
just not enough oxygen food going in
there start forgetting things and it's
called vastor dementia then there's
corov syndrome which is a deficiency of
a single vitamin this was discovered in
the late 1700s by a Japanese Naval
surgeon and um so we always prepare for
that one there's wariki corov it's the
same deficiency that one Vitamin Plus Ms
Ms multiple sclerosis mixed in with it
and then there's Alzheimer disease I've
seen people with all four dementias
Alzheimer's tile wave is fear that's
because there's 80 million baby boomers
coming along this came out in 2009
alsheimer is in a Relentless sub
trajectory it's kind of like that
obesity chart right and also the um that
is the Al's chart numbers look
particularly Grim for Baby Boomers
because they're on egg beaters egg white
omelet boneless skinless chicken breasts
and the worst possible thing is they
took the statin drugs to lower their
cholesterol talk about a perfect storm
for making alheim disease again reminder
realiz in the same sentence only a
doctor could do that aler is the only
disease amongst the top six killers in
the USA for which there's no prevention
cure treatment that's all a lie okay in
1992 the University of California San
Diego and the s Institute came out with
this study and they said if you take
somebody with Advanced aler disease and
you give them a high dose of vitamin E
they'll get better now this isn't some
comic book stuff this is a 10-year study
from the so Institute and the University
of California s San Diego medical
school so I I read this into my audio
cassette tape this is part of my audio
cassette tape I said vitamin E can ease
memory loss Alzheimer's victims which
means it cannot be genetic because
there's no genetic disease that you can
even help any little bit by giving a
vitamin or mineral so if you can get
some clinical Improvement by giving them
one vitamin that ain't genetic that's
simple stuff that's fourth grade biology
every Medical Association in in every
state United States went to their state
attorney generals and had them send me a
demand warrant making me prove what I
was saying was true otherwise they're
going to take my assets away and put me
in jail I don't know how they're going
put me in jail in 50 States but cut me
up I guess
and and so we had to send all 50 states
a certified copy of that newspaper plus
a copy of the CD they could say I was
just reading that so that's the first
amendment thing so all states except
Arizona and Michigan dropped the charges
had to go do kind of a pre-trial hearing
and everything in Michigan and Arizona
but the judge threw it out after they
saw my presentation everything and so
they had to pay my legal fees and
transportation I love that part okay
okay then in 2010 front cover story US
News will report America's best nursing
homes aging well obviously marketing to
the Baby Boomers what science reveals
about aging is your job killing you your
first baby Boomer's heart battle but
this is why I bought it seven habits
that lower the risk of alzer disease
what does that tell you it ain't genetic
if you can sleep two more hours a night
if you can walk around the block two
more times if you can eat a banana every
week that you weren't doing you can read
a little bit more read a book every
month and one of the things they mention
was read a book every month reduce your
risk of alzer disease it ain't genetic
so right there it says if it ain't
genetic and you get it late in life that
means we can prevent it and that means
we can get rid of
it
amen remember there's four different
dimensions so I like to treat for all
four well 10 years after that first
study I showed you with the vitamin E
John's Hopkins released a study that
they did in cash County that CA not C
but CA Valley area Utah and um this was
the bottom of a small sea or lake
thousands and thousands of years ago and
the mountains go all the way around it
this is laser flat they didn't have the
bulldozer flat CU it was just it's
bottom of a lake or Inland Sea so it's
was just flat 200 ft of top soil in
there and there's no restaurants I mean
these are very very religious Mormons
that live in there they're all from a
Scottish background everybody who moved
into that Valley came from Scotland for
some reason they all um uh converted to
Mormonism and they lived and ate they
all farmers and they all ate the food
they wouldn't even go to a restaurant
they're very religious people uh they're
kind of like the equivalent to the
Mormons of the Jewish kosher people are
to the Jewish people okay the Orthodox
Jewish people and um
they have uh a supplemental book to
their holy book okay uh and this holy
book supplement tells them what to eat
what not to eat just like the kosher
Jewish people Orthodox Jewish people
have their stuff they're not supposed to
eat and supposed stuff they're supposed
to eat right that's what they did here
well John's Hopkins how many of you
heard of John's Hopkins Baltimore very
famous medical school they sent a whole
team of guys out there they found 5,000
people in that Valley over the age of 65
they divided them in half and they gave
half of them 2500
for 10 years a vitamin supplement the
other half they gave a dummy pill double
blind randomized study gold study from a
one of the top medical schools in
America they published it in 2004 and I
bet your doctor didn't email you the
results if he didn't you need to fire
him I guarantee most of you be firing
your doctors the first study in 1992 was
just vitamin E I I was so excited about
that I said they need to give them all
90 but instead they just added vitamin C
to it we don't want to get too
aggressive here they just had of vitamin
C make a long story short they said
people taking the vitamin c and e over
the 10 years were 78% less likely to
have a diagnosis of Al disease and them
that
didn't 78% reduction in Risk by just
adding two vitamins to their diet now I
guarantee it's more complicated in that
because right now as we speak I'm having
in fact I'm going to be meeting with
these guys here um in a couple of weeks
they've been doing an analysis of the
soil for me in that Valley because those
two vitamins are a co-actor for some
mineral or mineral in there right now
I'm giving everybody everything so I
know they're getting it all CU they're
getting everything right but I guarantee
you there's some minerals in there that
are very high but any rate if you take
everything you're going to get
everything right but just think about
you can reduce your risk by 78% just
with
supplementation same people they're
homogeneous same cultural background
they're all from Scotland they're all
Farmers they all live in the same Valley
they're all the same religion they all
eat the same things all avoid the same
things I mean it's like laboratory rats
they every about as homogenous as you
can get Why did Why did um medical
school go there why did they go there
because you can't in Baltimore Maryland
you can't find two people who are like
let alone 5,000 that was pretty smart on
their part wasn't it so anytime your
doctor says it's genetic and there's no
way to prevent or cure liar liar pants
on fire okay well four years ago I
believe it was Ray McGregor's sister
he's from Greensboro and she was from
Charlotte and she's one of her
Associates one of our Distributors and
she called me four years ago and said my
brother Ry was diagnosed 8 years before
she called me and said which is 12 years
ago now and said he was diagnosed with
Alzheimer disease and the doctor says
genetic and I might as well get my
reservation in his nursing home right
now so i' be sure to have a space when
the time came blah blah blah and um it's
scaring me and and so I've took him to
neurological clinics I even went to the
medical school here in North Carolina
and um had the head of the Department of
Neurology examine him and he agreed with
the primary care physician that was alar
disease and when she called me four
years ago he had lost his memory
complete he was UN able to communicate
with grunts or barks or blinks or
raising a finger or anything he could
not communicate anyway we couldn't tell
if he was I never saw him this over the
phone um he would lay on the floor and
curl up in a in a fetal position so
anyway what I did for him was was say
okay look I'm going to treat him for all
four dimensions because we're kind of
late in the game here right I said well
thank you for calling me in early on the
case right he's in a hospice he's being
fed with a G tube so you got to get him
off the insure because insur is made 60%
by volume car oil trans fatty acids the
worst possible thing for a normal brain
let alone anybody with any brain disease
like Park disease MS Lugar disease or
any dementias no
Ure okay we need you to get your brother
off of Ure we have that shake we told
you about the Slender effects but if we
just make it with water he's going to
lose weight and what I want you to do is
make it with heavy whipping cream
because I want to rebuild his brain with
heavy whipping cream I want you to put
four eggs in it I want him to have two
servings of that a day through his G
tube have to whip it up real fine put
through the G tube and then I want him
to have four more I'm going have a total
of 12 eggs a day because I'm calculating
how much cholesterol I'm giving him and
rebuild the brain in case he does have
alimer disease
right not cook but raw then I want him
to have two healthy heart and brain
packs per month but I want him to have
four half doses a day split out during
the day mix it with milk get it through
the G tube that's how you're going to
get the other four eggs in there then in
case it's vaster Dimension I'm to take
three of the ultimate daily tablets
three times a day grind them up put them
in with that milk and the other stuff
and put them through the G tube because
it actually dilates arteries and and
improves blood
flow then I want to take three of our
de-stress capsules three times a day
that's three bottles a month because it
has that one vitamin that's deficient
when you have corov syndrome and M corov
syndrome he he got 28,000 times the
minimum daily requirement of that one
they want him to have selenium I want to
have nine of our selenium a day three at
breakfast three at lunch three dinner
three bottles a month in case he has
wary cor coughs I got rid of the plaque
in his brain from the MS then I need to
take 12 of our smart effects a day these
are dhas and epas which are the raw
materials for the brain to make
neurotransmitters for memory and
cognition problem solving in memory I'm
going to have 12 of those a day you had
to punct a little soft gel capsule
squeeze that in through the G2 she took
a six-month leave of absence because the
technicians and the doctors at the
hospice wouldn't do it she said I'm
going to give him the best shot I can
I'm going to take six months off of work
and do it and she calls me a week later
I told her to call me every two weeks
and give me kind of a progress report
cuz this is under controll situation she
personally would to do it every day so I
had Faith she was going to do it so she
calls me on the radio and the producer
says doc there's this lady screaming
about her brother with alimer it's a
week maybe something terrible has
happened put her on I'm going to quote
her exactly so bear with me it's very
emotional for me because I want to quote
for
you okay here we go so be prepared and
she she said to me quoting her now he's
C in one week's time he got dressed and
walked out did not have Alim disease Al
Seas it take me 9 to 12 months to
reverse but he had corov syndrome which
is curable in a week it's a simple
deficiency of a single vitam remember I
told you I gave him 28,000 times the
minimum daily requirement of that
vitamin because she gave me little
signals to make me think it was more
likely corov syndrome and Alzheimer's
disease so I kind of hedged Ray bet on
that one and it worked I do this a
thousand times a year now very simple
it's called corom syndrome the same
formula works for Parkin disease MS and
Lugar disease I have many many wealthy
uh I mean billionaires that we've
reversed their terminal Parkinson's
disease in three months they went from
being weeks away from Death to three
months later they perfectly normal okay
parkon dise same formula okay
arthritis 95% of arthritis is a simple
mineral deficiency disease starts out
osteopenia osteoporosis osteoarthritis
Eugen arthritis bone toone arthritis all
the same disease just different degrees
of
severity and you know one begets the
other as you go along if you're not
solve the problem we have the healthy
Bone and Joint for that one per 100 lbs
of body weight and um uh there's four
ingredients in there so you have to give
a full dose of all the ingredients twice
a day for a 200 lb person but I like
over 150 pounds I like them to have 15
of the glucogel a day which are the raw
materials to support and promote
maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tenons connective tissue disc
between the vertebrae bone matrix and
Bone itself it's actually a mix of condr
and sulfate um glucosamine sulfate um
hyaluronic acid and collagen it's all in
one capsule is this was the main message
in the uh Dead Doctors Don't Lie audio
cassette tape uh back in uh uh
1992 when that came out and of course uh
one guy branded me with that audio
casset tape I never thought my wildest
dreams that would be a big deal but one
guy bought 20 million of them for a buck
a piece his check cleared it was really
weird he got excited about it so I
thought man this must must be something
and since then I've sold 180 million so
you need to kind of change your story
it's 180 million now they're still going
out store 50,000 a week now 5% of
arthritis is rheumatoid arthritis 5% is
rheumat arthritis rheumat arthritis is
easily curable in two weeks rheumat
arthritis is a simple infection with a
bug called
micoplasma micoplasma is the cause of
rheumat arthritis it's not autoimmune
it's not a genetic disease it's not just
dumb luck it's not somebody's put a hex
on you it's just a simple infection it's
curable in two weeks with a antibod
called Minocycline like the little Bait
fish Minocycline take that Minocycline
it's gone you're still going to have
some damage so it might take you 30 60
90 days depending on the degree of
damage the healthy Bone and Joint pack
to regrow everything and then you're
done with it now the doctor will only
make $300 in office calls if he cures
you with that program pharmacist might
make a few bucks from the mocyc
prescription you've heard of mocyc is
member of the tetracycline family sure
if he treats you for 25 years he Mak
$750,000 joint Replacements all the side
effects of the drugs you got treat and
so he has to think for 310 of a
millisecond am I going to make 300 bucks
or I going to make 750,000 which way do
they all go there Monopoly no
competition and insurance pays if there
wasn't insurance you wouldn't mortgage
your house for $750,000 you just take
more aspirin or You' take Grandma's
herbs or you'd take healthy Bone and
Joint pack but insurance pays well I've
got it managed and you know the doctor
said the insurance will pay for my joint
replacement so I'm going that direction
I wouldn't want to spend $3 a day I need
it for my Starbucks Coffee okay this is
Andy Young's living room I was kind of
40 lbs heavier there but he' canceled
his D knee replacement and uh we rebuilt
his knees in 90 days and he's been a
very good friend of mine ever since now
this gal here was in a wheelchair for 10
years before I met her you recognize
some of these folks this gal here his
name is Willie Barrow anybody recognize
that name Willie Barrow Willie Barrow
was Dr King's accountant she made sure
that not a single penny was stolen from
the Civil Rights Movement you never
heard of any anything going there was no
Mischief with the money with the civil
rights movement and she is the one that
kept control of everything well I was
invited in to be this the featured
speaker of her 87th birthday party okay
it was at the rainbow push facility and
10 days she 87 years old 10 days after
she's on her program she got out of that
wheelchair and walked for the first time
in 10 years the coming epidemic of
arthritis why is there an epidemic
because there's 80 million baby boomers
come along and they follow the doctor's
Directions They exercise they drank
plenty of water and didn't take vitamins
and minerals it's a perfect storm for
obesity diabetes arthritis
Al disease oh yeah be sure to take the
stand drugs July 2002 the New England
Journal of Medicine Harvard Medical
School a team of orthopic Surgeons from
Harvard Medical School did a meta study
on 300,000 people from around the world
that had joint replacement they said
knee surgery hip surgery and shoulder
surgery for arthritis is worthless give
me 90 days give us 90 days if you have
anything along the line osteopenia
osteoporosis osteoarthritis arthritis
bone
arthritis no to the surgery suggestion
do not do it arthop surgery arthoscopic
surgery replacement do not do it give me
90 days first you can always get the
surgery can't you but I I I was
personally met a kid who's 7 foot 10
he's a high school kid 7 foot 10 in
Chicago his father's on the suicide
watch as we speak he had a little funny
feeling at the end of his high school
days here on the inside of his right
knee and and the father says look wait
wait the coach has an in with the arthop
surgeon at at Chicago Bulls if he looks
at you might get on that team and the
kids I don't know I I don't feel good
about that and the father let's talk
about so he goes in there and the GU oh
yeah we need to do arthoscopic out
scrape the cartilage and everything will
be fine he gives the kid Mera they put
in a hyperbaric chamber for you know two
months and gave Ivy antibiotics and they
wound up cutting his leg off now how do
you play basketball with one and a half
legs and the doctor gets a walk I could
have fix that kid I can't regrow his leg
if he was a salamander I
could some of you know enough about
biology
okay four years later November 2006 the
same group of doctors from Harvard
Medical School orthopedic surgeons
published in the journal American
Medical Association said surgery
unnecessary for aciatica low back pain
peripheral neuropathies numbness burning
pain in the feet uh bulging disrupture
disc um restless leg syndrome any of
that kind of stuff all unnecessary give
me 90 days we regrow disc we fix backs
all the time do not get Sur you can
always get the surgery that's what Andy
young said if you can't fix me 9 I'll
just go get the surgery you know I'm
willing to take you know I've been
suffering with this for 25 years so
once's another couple of
months okay type 2 diabetes is a simple
mineral deficiency why is there going to
be a type two diabetes epidemic 80
million baby rumors come along exercise
drink plenty of water and don't take
vitamins and minerals it's a simple
mineral deficiency disease and so we
have what we call the healthy blood
sugar pack you take one healthy blood
sugar pack for 100 pounds of body weight
and uh take your fasting blood sugar
every morning before you medicate
yourself cuz you can have your blood
sugar 300 every morning with medication
with injectable insulin and if you take
our program the night before it could be
68 the next day so don't medicate
yourself without taking your fasting
blood sugar
first I don't get the easy ones I always
get the tough ones okay this Gang Green
of the foot I get him with Gang Green of
the foot I get him with Gang Green of
the legs this fell here his name is Buck
stepin um came to me it was 260 lb his
blood sugar was 371 with injectable
insulin
doctors told him he was going to die
within 3 months he was so bad with
diabetes and all his side effects
complications that whether they took his
feet off or not he was going to die in
three months if they did amputate his
feet he was going to die if they didn't
amputate his feet so he sold his house
moved up to ugene Argan with his family
so he could spend his last weeks or
months with his family but he came to a
Convention of ours and I told him look
you have nothing to lose you're 260lb
guy want you on three healthy bone and
excuse me three healthy blood sugar
packs
which he did and in 6 weeks time his
blood sugar instead of being 371 with
injectable insulin it was in fact then
68 he's an ex diabetic we gave him
addition to that we gave him um nine of
our ultimate daily tablets to get
circulation down through that foot we
put in our collidal silver soaked on
cotton balls in between his toes put a
clean cotton sock on there change that
dressing four times a day and in two
months time that's the same foot save
both his feet he's perfectly normal now
and ex diabetic we can make America
diabetes free in 60 90 days planet is
safe somebody has to have the will to do
it we have the ability to do it give me
90 days for you just keep taking your
antibiotics keep that Gang Green from
getting worse and give me some time and
the odds are will be able to fix this do
not get amputations first without trying
something else if it's not cholesterol
that clogs your arteries what is it is
the inflammation we already talked about
the inflammation from fried foods
processed Meats with nitrates nitrites
oils and in many cases gluten wheat
barley R
oats okay now this fell here is a pastor
and you may know him uh he's um Tyrone
krider from Southside Chicago he's a
black Pastor kind of interesting guy for
a black Pastor isn't he brothers and
sisters are black his mom and dad is
black all his kids are
black but he has green eyes and he's
whiter than me why is that because on
his mama's side on his daddy's side they
had some white guy or gal several
Generations ago and just by dumb luck
the recessive genes came together when
his daddy fertilized Mama's egg and and
that's how that happened so he's an
interesting guy very interesting man uh
he's a pastor of a big very big black
church in the South Side Chicago Tyrone
cder is his name he's 300 lbs in this
picture he when I met him at 1 o'clock
in the morning in the lobby of a hotel
he brought a letter of introduction from
Martin Luther King III who was his
roommate in morous college when they
were college kids and um Martin and I
worked with Martin for a long time and
he was on the heart transpl plant list
he actually had a bracelet he says if
this thing starts buzzing the lights
going off just like that thing they give
you we in a restaurant waiting for a
table he says if this thing goes off
starts buzzing the lights started
blinking I'm out of here don't think I'm
rude but I have I'm on the heart
transplant list uh I have congestive
heart failure which is a def he didn't
say this I'm telling you this he had
congestive heart fail which is a
deficiency of a single vitamin is
curable in a couple of weeks congestive
heart Fe the most common cause of heart
death in America's deficiency of a
single my vitamin is curable in a couple
of weeks selenium is for the other
disease he had selum is a mineral and he
had it it was a hypertrophic cardiopathy
heart disease which a deficiency of a
single mineral selenium he also had
coronary artery disease which is caused
by inflammation he that Fried Chicken
after church every Sunday right he was a
big man so ate a lot of it and he
brought a briefcase kind of this size
and it had 27 prescription drugs in
there that he was taken three of those
prescription drugs were diuretics one of
which was Lasix and he couldn't walk
from here to that wall without holding
on to the chairs that love he want to
get a cup of coffee and he's walk he
stop every two or three chairs have had
so much fluid in his chest and his belly
it tells me immediately that that those
those diuretics weren't working that's
because he wasn't absorbing he had a
gluten intolerance he wasn't absorbing
the medicine so you run into people who
say well yeah I can take a thousand
aspirins it doesn't work but I got this
terrible headache it won't work they got
a gluten they just can't absorb them
you're not what you eat you are what you
absorb it's kind of different than the
old Addies you are what you eat is
really you are what you absorb so if you
can't absorb it no matter what you're
doing for good doesn't matter you have
to be able to absorb it so at any rate
had 27 prescription drugs okay look I'm
going to treat you for all four all four
heart diseases and I I didn't have it
that time this was six years ago I
didn't have the um ASAP at that time so
I said look what I want you to do is
take three of the um healthy heart and
brain packs per month here be taking
three doses a day of six different
Vitamineral products just from that
that's your basic stuff your body needs
I'm going to have you take nine of my
selenium a day three breakfast lunch in
there that's three bottles a month I you
take um 12 of the ultimate daily tablets
four four and four that's two bottles a
month because they're big bottles
because we got to deal with the clogged
arteries because you have coronary
artery disease then I want you to take
um the um the cenum was for the
cardiopathy heart disease then for the
congestive heart failure I want you to
take what we call the d-stress capsules
which has that one vitamin that's
missing when you have the um congestive
heart failure want you take 12 of those
a day that's your primary disease
that'll be three bottles a month and
then you got to give up the fried foods
and the processed meats and the nitrates
and nitrates the oils and the gluten the
wheat bar R oats he I ain't doing it
that's too complicate all that stuff and
and diet change his wife is only 100
pounds her name is Regina she you're
going to do it she says you're going
even do it if you're going to do it not
going to do it I'm going to give it to
you rectly he said okay I'll do it I've
never seen anybody talk to a pastor like
that but she did it and got away with it
okay she was so angry with him that he
said it was too complicated so I told
call me every two weeks that's my deal
call me in two weeks she calls me in a
week that Friday this was Sunday morning
1:00 she called me this is God's truth
this is a pastor you can check with she
calls me a week later she says okay
Tyrone went in this morning he' been
taking a physical every Friday for three
years CU they told him he had so many
complications it had to be a train wreck
in Chicago and 500 dead people for him
to get a heart he's so low in the list
and so he said we got to do a physical
on you every Friday so we have a running
um knowledge of how you are so when the
heart comes in we don't want to dine in
the ice bucket we're waiting for a lab
test we're just going to slam the heart
in you if if it comes he paid him $5,000
cash every Friday for 3 years $20,000 a
month cash you think they weren't using
him for an ATM machine they were
giggling all the way to the country club
every Friday okay so anyway he goes in
they call his wife say look your husband
didn't turn on his cell phone pH we want
you to turn around send him back do not
give him anything do not give when he
comes home do not give him anything turn
around send him back give him $5,000
going to redo everything we think we we
think we've mixed all his data up with
somebody else's so you know what's
happening already right
so he goes in he thought he'd won the
lottery because not only was his
cardiologist there there's another
cardiologist and there's three heart
transplant surgeons who he' met before
he says they got my heart they got my
heart this is it they did they did all
the tests again they took him off of all
27 prescription drugs he took him off
the heart transplant list and deemed him
cured and now he is preaching before he
couldn't preach he had to sit you know
on the stage and then he had an
assistant pastor preach for like 5 years
because he couldn't preach he couldn't
breathe it so full of
fluid do not let your pediatricians give
your kids statin drugs they're talking
about starting at 8 years old the
American Academy of Pediatrics has now
released new guidelines they want the
kids that have lowfat milk and take
start cholesterol testing and they want
them to take statin drugs do not let
them do it because these kids will not
live to be 20 if they start on stting
drugs at
8 now this is my
favorite this is the last one on
cholesterol and I can talk about high
blood pressure which is very very good
then I'm done in my favorite cholesterol
article scientific article New England
Journal medicine Harvard Medical School
Dr karna was the um professor of of
clinical medicine at Harvard taught
medical students how to be a doctor and
in the Outpatient Clinic normal
cholesterol an 88-year old man Frank who
eats 25 eggs a day he comes in for his
annual physical there's like a dozen
students around Dr Kern and um he said
look we um are so proud of you you're 88
years old all your chemistries are
normal I mean it's just really
interesting and so we want to reward you
we're going to we decided since we get
lots of free samples and everything
we're going to give you a free Supply a
one-year free supply of of Viagra and he
he stands up he puts his you know picks
his belt up throws his shoulders back
and say I don't need none of that Viagra
stuff I'm pretty good in that area they
really and all the students are giggling
you know and cuz I called Dr Kern and
asked him he said well the students were
really giggling over that one and um I
said well what makes you so sure you're
in good shape over that and he says well
I eat 25 eggs a day and you can imagine
Dr Kern a medical doctor from Harvard
somebody eating 25 eggs day and their
cholesterol is in the normal range so
he's got to have a heart attack right so
they all run in the lab they rerun all
the blood sure enough it's still normal
comes back out he's sitting down he says
he's patting his brow with his
handkerchief cuz he's sweating he say
okay tell me why I eat 25 eggs a day so
Frank stands up again pulls his b belt
up throws his shoulder back and says cuz
it makes me more studly I are a stud now
I want you think about it cholesterol
makes up 95% of testosterone if you're
on an egg-free diet there ain't nobody
home you're eating 25 eggs a day
Yahoo okay high blood pressure quickly
is not a genetic disease a simple
mineral
deficiency salt has nothing to do with
hood pressure If you swell up you get
edema when you use salt is because you
have low blood protein eat more eggs to
get your protein up you won't have the
swelling after years of telling healthy
people that too much salt isn't good for
them researchers still don't have solid
evidence to back up the claim doctors
say the stupidest things constantly like
there's no prevention for Alzheimer
disease okay so you know I'm a farmer
and so you put a salt block out in the
pasture for cows and horses and whatnot
is there anybody out there telling a
horse or cow they're limited to one lick
a day no I refuse to believe my patients
my human patients are Dumber in a cow so
just salt your food just salt it salt it
salt it salt it go crazy bathe in it
salt it put on your arms put in your
ears put salt everywhere go for salt
said God says go forth and be as the
salt of the earth and he lives forever
doctors say he restrict salt and they
only live be 56 I'm going with God on
the salt thing so there's two things you
need to do in addition to firing your
doctor it starts with this J American
medal Association August 2003 they
talked about an herb called dark
chocolate not milk chocolate dark
chocolate that has a substance called
Flav lower blood pressure now it doesn't
give you the mineral that will
permanently cure it but it will lower it
like a pharmaceutical will without the
complications of pharmaceutical has
flavonols in the dark chocolate okay so
when that came out 2003 we came out with
a liquid dark chocolate called Coco
jevity plus it has the flavonols in it
plus 3,000 of those oric points in it
per ounce they take 2 ounces a day we we
are a coffee company we sell organic
coffee and so we want you to put an
ounce of this twice a day in your cup of
organic coffee make your own Mocha Cafe
right why give Howard all the money do
it yourself plus you get the flavonol to
lower your blood pressure without the
complications of the um pharmaceutical
we also have pieces of chocolate each
the size of a pad of butter come in
boxes of 100 or 20 it's a little cheaper
than boxes of 100 because there's less
packaging each piece the size of a pad
of butter has the flavonols in it the
low blood pressure is gluten-free
glycemic friendly so even diabetics can
take it uh two of these will give you
33,000 of those oric points so I take
six of these a day I never take less
than six a day so I get 100,000 oric
points remember these Long Live people
take in 20,000 to 50,000 Americans take
in 1500 i' take in 100,000 I'm going to
end my presentation with a little
summary here goes like this if I were to
live to be 112 nobody would pay
attention to it they say well you know
wallet can't claim that's his stuff
because people live to be 112 all the
time so I have to live to be 200 I'm I'm
pointing to
Centerfield I'm pointing to center field
like Babe Ruth right I'm pointing to
center field I'm saying I'm going for
200 f make it to 179 that'll still be
better than 112 right but to get to 179
I got to shoot far 200 so I'm pointing
to center field now remember here's Babe
Ruth two outs two strikes and bottom of
the ninth and they're down by three runs
he steps out of the batteries box you
know knocks the mud off his cleats and
he points out to center field everybody
including the pitcher knew what he was
talking about he's going for a grand
slam so they'd win by one run they were
down by three runs that pitcher he was
smart he' just thrown a ball into the
dirt and walked him cuz he could
probably handle the next B but instead
he's too arrogant and he threw that
pitch and babe R hit that grand slam and
they won by one run I'm pointing
Centerfield say I'm going for 200 okay
now I'm doing everything right and these
people live with me they eat with me uh
we spend a lot of time I give 300
lectures a year they'll be with me for a
couple of days and they pass me off to
somebody else they'll be with me for a
couple days they pass me off to somebody
else so I eat with a lot of people and
they see me take my stuff every day I do
it twice a day I've been taking the 90
cents of nutrients twice a day since I
was nine that's why I'm been into a
doctor in 65 years I don't have any
health problems have no health problems
okay so the message here is I started
doing it when I was nine I mean you can
start now right I have four kids eight
grandkids and four great-grandkids and
all the stuff before they're conceived
all through their pregnancy and from the
moment they're born and none of them
ever been sick none of my kids my
grandkids my greats have ever been sick
so the point is if we all do this basic
thing avoid the bad stuff the fried
foods the processed Meats with nitrates
and nitrites the oils the S dressings a
mayonnaise the cooking oils if you eat
canned fish it's fine but eat them
packed in water mustard tomato sauce not
oil use your brains use your heart save
your families you have to do these
things and if if we we can save America
but we're going to have to do it we
can't wait on the doctors to make up
their minds they're going to be a
thousand years behind it took them a
thousand years to give up the idea that
disease was caused by evil spirits and
so it's going to take him a thousand
years to give up the genetics thing even
though that the guy who got the Nobel
Prize card said it's not genetics it's
vitamins and minerals okay you're going
to have to take the ball and run with it
if you do that we can save ourselves if
you don't do that you will be burying
your children that's what it comes down
to all right so uh we're looking for
lots of help I'm not here just to sell
another bottle of minerals I don't make
any money personally from selling
minerals and things uh I do these
lectures for free I make my living from
selling books and so um I I did that
purposely so doctors couldn't take away
from the message well he's selling them
vitamins minerals he'll tell you
anything to sell them vitamins well I
don't make anything from it I purposely
don't so they can't say that and so
we're looking for lots of help we're in
a major growth phase right now because
the medical system is having troubles of
its own uh the government is in trouble
financially uh and um the econom is in
trouble financially and so people are
coming to us now who wouldn't have
looked at us before so we not we need
lots of help and we give car bonuses and
stock options we give um tax benefits
because you own your own business you
can't get these tax benefits When when
you're a good employee you have no tax
benefits When You're a good employee but
when you're when you own your own
business even a little $10 business like
young J
you actually can get you get back most
of your withholdings so is that for one
time a one time fee of $10 every year
get back thousands of dollars whoa you
don't have to think about that for three
seconds pretty simple stuff okay so
doesn't get any better than that God
bless yall thank you very much